- Man, I'm tired.
- Gamers, gamers, gamers, you
didn't even have class today
and you're like more dead
than when you had class.
- You're doing the Skype?
- Yeah.
- What's wrong with you?
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to this episode of "Trash Taste"
where I don't know what
we're talking about today,
but I'm joined by the
boys who also don't know
what we're talking about today.
- It's good to have a normal episode.
Like we've had a few now where, God,
I'm finding it hard to
talk now, Jesus Christ,
I need to like fire up my brain.
- There're so many things
that I wanted to talk about
like a week, two weeks
ago, but I just couldn't
cause we had like themed episodes.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like, okay, for
example, I'm gonna just go
right into the topics.
- Sure.
- Okay, okay.
I've had a few topics that
I wanna talk about as well,
but we can just quick
fire through every topic
that we wanted to talk about.
- Go for it.
- About three weeks ago, I was scrolling
on the YouTube.com app at
like midnight, pretty late,
I was getting ready for bed.
Some reason, this genre of video
is starting getting recommended to me,
which was about like dangerous caves.
- Okay.
- Have you ever seen these videos?
- No.
- Maybe I have.
- Basically, it's just
about caves that people go,
I think it's literally called caving,
where they go and explore caves.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Is it like uncharted and
unexplored caves or is it like-
- There's sometimes uncharted
ones, sometimes explored ones.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it was just one of
those things where I was like,
I do not understand why people do this.
Like I could not fathom it.
So there was this one
video, I can't remember
what it was called, it was
talking about a cave in the UK
and this cave had a section in it, right?
Where the person has to
crawl through the cave
on there, like you cannot
turn around, right?
So you are crawling like this, right?
For like a mile.
- [Joey] Oh, I feel like I've seen that
and it's like just wide enough
to fit a single person, right?
- One person go in it
and you can't turn around
until you get to the end of
the part or the middle section,
where there's a part where you
can stand up and turn around.
And it was like very--
- That sounds horrible.
- I could, to myself, I'm like, yo wow!
- That is a claustrophobe's
worst nightmare.
- I watch some of these
videos and I get anxiety
just from like, not even watching it,
but just from the idea, thinking about it
and some people do this with
uncharted caves as well,
which to me just blows my fucking mind
and I get, if we don't do it,
somebody is gonna have to
be crazy enough to do it.
- Like who dead ass looks at like a hole
but just goes on forever and is like,
"I'ma crawl through that."
- Yeah, so it's horrifying
cause there was like the
thing about this video
and the cave is blocked off
now, so you can't get into it.
Like you still can in
different ways apparently,
but what ended up happening
was there was a flood
while four people were
inside the cave and yeah,
they obviously drowned
cause they were stuck in the
part where you were crawling.
- This reminds me of that
scene from "Japan Sinks."
- Yeah, it's so horrible
and I was like, I have seen,
I've watched documentaries
about horrible stuff,
you watch some videos
like all kind of horrible stuff
and nothing got my
anxiety going like this.
- Yeah.
- And it was just awful,
I was like, oh my God.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And yeah, there's YouTubers,
who their whole channel is
that they just explore caves
that have never been explored.
Which is like simultaneously
the coolest thing,
but also why the fuck would you,
why don't you just like review stuff?
I don't know, why don't you like react?
- You could've made your YouTube channel
around anything else.
- It's so cool though
cause like you sit there
and there's someone was
asking one of these YouTubers,
"Like why do you do it, why
are you climbing caves?"
It's like, "Oh, cause it's
like the only place on Earth
where like no one can communicate to you
and no one knows anything about
and it's a secret to discover"
and then that way, I kind of--
- Go to space.
- Yeah.
- Go to space, I don't
know about that, Joey.
Oh yes, I'll get on my rocket ship, Joey.
- I feel it's a lot cooler.
- Maybe, but there was this one video
about this cave in, I think it was Utah.
It's called like the Nutty Putty Cave
- [Joey] All right.
- And that's because apparently,
the soil is of a texture-
- Nutty Putty.
- It was Nutty Putty.
- Yeah, so apparently,
the cave was like putty.
- That just sounds like a euphemism.
- And there's like, so let me
paint a picture of this cave.
So it's basically, this cave
is essentially just one cave
that just goes down, deep
and it was a pretty well-explored cave,
so most of this cave was all really,
like really well-documented
and mapped out.
So it wasn't a cave for
like super, super experts,
it was like, oh, if you'd
like caving, go in there,
it's fine and there's two
paths points in this cave.
One were you supposed to go down
and one that is too thin to go down.
- [Joey] All right, right.
- And the other part is
called like the birth canal
in this cave, it's so tight, right?
That you have to grab,
once you get your hands
through this cave, you have to
pull yourself vertically down
cause it's too tight, so
you have to pull yourself.
So what happened was, right?
The reason why this cave is
now closed and why it's famous
is that there was a story where this guy
went down the wrong way and he thought,
because he it was getting really tight,
that, "Oh, I'm in the right point
"cause this is the birth
canal, as it's called."
- Right.
- All right.
- So instead of thinking,
ah, maybe I should like stop,
wait for my mate, he's like,
"All right, I should keep going."
So he keeps going down
a point that's too small
and just get stuck headfirst down a cave.
- [Garnt] Oh my God.
- And we're talking like proper
like tight, the whole thing
and it's really brutal,
cause this guy's stuck there
for 12 hours and there's
like tons of rescue attempts
from like people and eventually
just dies cause obviously,
he's upside down for 12 hours
and it's just horrible
hearing this and also,
could you imagine being a rescue worker?
Like having to get someone out of a cave?
- I felt like being a
rescue worker in that sense,
you're as likely to die
rescuing the person--
- Yeah.
- At one point, one of the
rescue worker get stuck with him
because he tries to go
down the same way just
to pull him out and
gets stuck, but luckily,
they get the rescue worker out,
but then I was thinking like,
is this just a bunch of people
who are rescue workers?
Who are trained in like cave rescue?
Cause that seems like harder
than the actual caving.
- Yeah, like you already have to be good
at exploring a cave, right?
- I mean, how can you
even be properly trained
for an environment like this?
- Yeah, yeah, because surely,
I feel like that's such a specialized job.
- [Joey] Yeah.
Cause you have to set up a
bunch of winches in a cave
that's not set up for any kind of--
- Yeah, also, like what life
choices make you decide, yeah,
you know what?
I'm gonna do something
that's even more dangerous
than cave diving
and that's helping people
who get stuck cave diving.
- At least people who skydive
or do risky stuff like that,
at least you get a quick
death if you fuck up,
but with like caving--
- That's the part that fucked me up,
is that if you're stuck, you're stuck.
- It's a slow death.
- It's just a slow death
and you're in a tight space.
Ooh, I'm getting anxiety
just talking about this.
- I'm not even claustrophobic
and that makes me--
- Yeah, I was like exploring caves,
that sounds kind of
cool, I'm down for that.
Exploring caves where, I once
I go in, I can't turn around,
that scares the shit out of me.
That sounds terrifying.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I wanna turn, I wanna
be like fuck, go back.
Because if also, more often than not,
it's recommended
obviously not to go alone.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- What happens if the guy in
front of you starts panicking?
- Yeah.
- And you're the one behind him.
- Cause there's nothing you can do.
- Yeah
- You're like,
cause then you're gonna start
panicking cause you're like,
fuck, I'm stuck, the guy
in front of me is stuck
cause he's freaking out,
should I be freaking out?
He told me this was a good idea, fuck!
- Like in the horror movies
where you're in a group,
there's a group and then someone
says, "Oh, let's split up,
"that's the smart thing
to do" and you think,
who in real life would actually do that?
And I feel like these are the people
who are just like making the decisions
where you're just questioning,
why the are you making
this decision right now?
This seems like a really stupid decision.
- That's why I hate most
like modern horror movies
because they always throw in that trope,
as if people watching this
in the cinemas are like,
"Finally, someone made a good choice
"in a horror movie, to split up."
- Also, another scary thing
about being stuck underground,
no signal, so you can't call for help.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, fuck!
- The only reason in
that Nutty Putty thing
is why someone got help because
his brother was with him
and was like, "Oh, he's stuck"
and went up to get help.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But that's brutal, imagine watching
just your family member just die.
- Just slowly die.
- Yeah, that's horrible, yeah.
- Yeah, I can't fucking imagine it.
- Sorry to start this
podcast on a morbid note.
- And to top it off,
it's not even like a cool sounding place
to die either, it's like--
- Is that cool?
What are you like, bro,
at least die cool bro,
what the fuck?
- My brother got stuck in a cave.
- Yeah, yeah, I know,
it's like there's like a
difference between like,
Oh yeah, my friend got stranded
in death valley and died
versus my brother got stuck
in the Nutty Putty and died.
It's like, it's a little unfortunate.
- This sad as well, cause in
the part of the story as well,
it's like he just had like
two newborn kids or something.
- Ooh!
- And it's like, why?
It's like the video starts.
He had a kid, he decided to
celebrate by going caving
and I'm like, no, why?
- Yeah, It's funny cause
I've been recommended
like I would say not like a
similar genre of YouTube videos,
but just like in the opposite
sense, which is just YouTube
was who just climbed really high places.
- Oh!
- Oh, the over climbers.
- And to like--
- I kind of get that, I don't know why.
- I don't.
- I don't like similarly how
watching these cave divers,
you get like a claustrophobic.
I get vertigo watching these people
just climb really high places.
- I also have a fear of
heights, so just watching it.
- I guess I can understand
Max I'm like, all right.
One, normally climbing is like
arguably climbing a tall skyscrapers,
probably safer than going
down a cave that's unexplored.
- I mean, there's a difference
between the feeling of being trapped
and just falling from a very high place.
I can see why you get
that sense of freedom
which is exactly the opposite
of what you're getting.
- Yeah, that's what I can understand that.
We get the view and it's pretty cool,
I kind of get it even though
I know it's in the same.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And normally, I'm not
going to lie either way,
fin apostle--
- Yeah, yeah, because like
I go recommend this video
and the title of this video was,
"Reflecting On The Day I Almost Died"
and I'm just like,
oh man, this is getting
a bit too real here
and it's just this guy who is climbing up
this really tall building
in Hong Kong, right?
And it's just like this
POV shot and it's just
him doing commentary over it.
- [Joey] All right.
- And so he climbs up
this really tall building
in the middle of a, like
from kind of like dawn.
So before the sun rises and
by the time he gets to the top
the sun starts rising
and so you have this
really tall skyscraper
and on top of this skyscraper,
there's just like this
really rickety scaffolding
that goes like off like
another mile or something.
You know what I mean?
- Right, right.
- And so he starts climbing
up this when it's like dark
and then by the time he gets
to the top, the sun has risen
and he can see the view
and then it starts raining
- Oh no.
- And he's up there by
himself and in the commentary,
he says that, "I had two choices,
"either I could wait up
there, wait out the rain
"and just kind of risk.
"Someone would see me and
getting a rescue attempt
"and I'd probably get arrested
"or I could just attempt to climb down
"even though I would be more
likely to slip off and die."
So of course--
- I'd climb down.
- He decides to climb down.
(all laughing)
Like getting arrested and being rescued.
- This is literally the
horror movie split up
or stay together.
- No, that's what I'm saying, right?
These people make the decisions
to do what we see as
like the dammer decision.
- But I feel like if
you're the type of person
who's gonna climb a skyscraper,
you're gonna be the type of guy
who climbs down a skyscraper.
- I mean, I guess in his
head he was like either way
I have to climb down, so I
might as well just do it now.
- I think there also is
a fair amount of people
who would rather die than be arrested.
- Maybe, probably.
- Maybe.
- No, I genuinely believe
there's a sacks of people like that.
I don't want a criminal record
so bad, I'd rather not exist.
- I'm gonna die here it
before I turn to all of you.
- I think there's people
who would rather take that risk, honestly.
- Yeah, probably.
- Cause there's some countries,
especially where you get that
shit, oh your life's ruined.
- True, true.
- Yeah.
- America.
America they don't,
I mean, most of most
developed countries, bigs up.
- Yeah, I mean like it's, I
mean, I find it interesting
to watch people go through this stuff,
but yeah, I mean, I
could never do it myself.
I think the most I would
wanna do is skydive
and maybe bungee jump,
but the more I hear about bungee jumping,
the less I wanna go through it.
- For me bungee jumping is a hard pass.
- Well, I think it's bungee jumping,
it very much depends on
where you're doing it
and what company you're doing it with
or is it some dude and his
mate with a truck and bungee.
- Are you in a country with
health and safety regulations?
That's the biggest thing I think about.
- I hear people would like doing it
in like places where I'm like,
I don't think you be bungee jumping there.
- I've seen and heard more
bungee jumping accidents happen
than skydiving accidents,
so just like weighing out the ratio,
I find that skydiving
might be slightly better.
- More so bungee jump over
like water more often than not
and you don't wanna slap that water.
- Yeah, exactly.
- No, yeah.
- And bye-bye skin.
- Yeah.
- Water fucking hurts when
you slap it at that stage.
- Yeah.
- That's speed, sorry.
- I mean, it hurts when
you're like belly float
from like two meters up.
- Yeah.
(Garnt and Joey laughing)
- Let alone like 30 meters.
- I do wonder, I'm like what causes,
like what happens in your,
are you born wanting to do
extremes like explore caves
or go to extreme heights?
Is that like something you're born with?
Or is that something you like?
- It has to be something you're born with?
All right?
- Or is that something
that like over your life,
something happens when
you're a kid and it just.
- No, because like I feel
that from a young age,
there's always like the kids
who are going to be like,
"Yeah, I'm gonna climb
this really tall tree.
"Watch me do it."
- I was like that as a kid.
I would climb anything and
then I don't know what,
I think maybe the first
time you fall over badly
and you're like, fuck, this
shit actually hurts if you fall.
- I think it's a difference between
when you fall off that
tree and you hurt yourself,
it's the difference between,
fuck, I'm never doing that again
or fuck, that was worth it.
- Yeah, can you pinpoint the moment
at any point in your
life where you've like,
you know exactly where your
fear came from for something.
I mean, your B, right?
- My B one.
I still have that memory to this day.
- For me, well, I'm afraid of heights,
but like not to bad, like it depends on--
- I think like this,
there was a little
experiment on kids, right?
There're some kids are
born, like people are born
with naturally a fear of heights.
- Yeah.
- Right, right, but I feel
that my fear of heights
came from the fact that
at my parents' place,
we have this kind of spiral
staircase that goes down.
- Oh shit, did you fall?
- And I fell down that.
- Oh no.
- Yeah and luckily I
didn't like break any bones
or like hurt myself that badly,
but I think I was only maybe
like two or three years old
when I did and it's the
earliest memory I have
of me just falling down
and I'm pretty sure
that caused a slight,
maybe like fear of heights or something.
- Doesn't it scare you
that like little things
happen to you as a kid could
just like, fuck you up?
- Yeah.
- It makes me scared
to have kids, I'm like,
whoa, what if I like accidentally give him
like too much broccoli?
And he won't have chicken
and broccoli ever again.
Man, like I traumatized him, right?
How do I know what's
gonna traumatize the kid?
- Hold on, that's the first
thing you come up with.
- I don't know.
- Getting traumatized
with chicken and broccoli.
- If my kid, right?
Doesn't eat the fucking cross,
I'm gonna be sitting down the table
with like the bottle
of whiskey being like,
why do they all go wrong?
- Where's the fuck go that one?
- I used to be really claustrophobic.
I don't really get that anymore,
but I used to be really much the kid.
I know exactly why and
it took me like years
to realize like, oh, that
probably was traumatizing.
So one time our parents were out
and it was me and my
brothers messing around
and we though, bro,
that's just a suitcase.
We can do so much fun stuff
with a suitcase for some reason.
So for some reason I
think me and my brothers
decided we're gonna take
turns locking each other
in the suitcase, right?
So, I don't know why
we decided to do this,
again we were like fall four or five,
I forgot how old we were.
So I got locked in the
suitcase, bear in mind,
for some reason I thought
I should eat my Coco Puffs
in the suitcase.
(Joey and Garnt giggling)
So I was in the suitcase just
eating Cocoa Puffs, right?
My brothers--
- What was the point of this.
What what'd you get out of this?
- I legitimately don't
know why we did this.
I just have this memory
and then they started--
- It's just a kid thing to do, right?
- And then my older brother
thought it'd be funny
to start flipping the
suitcase with Cocoa Puffs
and then that was where I drew the line,
I was like, get me out, get me out of here
that he wouldn't let me
out for like 10 minutes
and I was like--
- I feel as well with that
kind of like childhood trauma,
it really depends on like
what your siblings did to you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I mean, I'm very glad
that I had siblings
cause I feel like man, I don't know,
I learned a lot of valuable lessons.
- I think it's because me and my sister
we kind of like think the
same way in a lot of things,
so like we wouldn't do
something to the other person
that we would hate to do.
- See this is is if you have--
- Only child, whoa!
- When you have like three
brothers, like I said man,
it's like fucking "Wrestle Mania."
It's like we would like
genuinely have like full
fist fights, we'd like punch
each other in the face,
all that stuff.
- Yeah, I hear brothers
would like Sydney and Russell
had a similar thing where like,
apparently they would just like
punch the out of each other
and that's just like sibling love, I guess
- But we didn't do it often,
but if like if stuff got really like bad,
like we had a really bad argument,
like we pretty end up fighting.
(Garnt giggling)
- Yeah.
- I mean, going back
to, with a fear thing,
do you know what fear like fascinates me?
I forgot what the name is,
like Tyraphobia or something.
- I had that.
- The one with like the holes.
- [Joey] Trypophobia?
- Yeah, Trypophobia.
The one where you like see
like a lot of small holes--
- Yeah, that one makes me feel disgusting.
- Cause like I didn't have a fear of this
and I think that literally
was a fear that got garnered
because of the internet.
- Yeah.
- Because we had like the
lily pond plants in Thailand
and I grew up with them,
so the little seeds.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- So I was used to seeing
this site everywhere.
So I had no fear of it
and then watching enough
fucking YouTube videos about it,
about this fear, I slowly
gained it over time
because I just saw these
different like fucking--
- Disgusting, yeah.
- Disgusting Photoshop edits.
- For me it wasn't even
like a YouTube video.
It was literally just typing
Trypophobia onto Google images
and just the first thing you see
is just this row and row.
- I mean, don't fucking show any pictures.
- Don't show it, don't
show it in the video,
but you guys if you want to
then go for it, I'm warning you though.
It's fucking gross.
- I'm kind of glad that I had that though
cause that made me like understand.
Cause when I was growing up,
I didn't really have, again,
even though I was claustrophobic,
I'm not really anymore,
I don't give a shit now.
Like I feel that that helped me understand
when people have fears
that don't make sense.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because before that
I didn't really get it.
Like if someone was
scared of like falling,
I'm like, oh it's just a
fall and you'll be fine.
That's a little bit of height, it's safe,
but now I get it, cause
from that, I'm like,
this makes no sense why
a bunch of little circles
make me feel gross, but now I get it.
- My fear of heights is really weird
because it's only like
certain levels of heights
that get me queasy.
- Cause like if you go up
to like the Tokyo Tower.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- There's parts of it where
the floor is made out of glass.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah!
- So you can see that.
- I'm totally okay with that,
but you take me onto the balcony
of like a 10 story building
and make me look down, that fucks me up.
Yeah, I think it's because
it might be because
like say with like Tokyo Tower,
like the glass thing, right?
Like, you know, that is safe.
Like you could stand on
that, you can jump on that.
- Like you trust the engineering.
- Yeah, I do.
It's like they wouldn't,
this is Japanese standards of engineering.
They wouldn't put this
here if there was a fear
that somebody could jump on this
and you could break through it, right?
So I know I can stand
on that, look down on it
and fuck around with it
because I know that's safe
- Fuck around with it, what are you doing?
Getting your chisel out.
- No, I could like fucking stamp on it
and jump around the stuff
just to like freak out
whoever I'm with and I'm fine with that.
That doesn't scare me at all
cause I know that's safe,
but you put me onto like a balcony
and I know nobody won't do it,
but the fear of somebody
could come behind me right now
and just push me over the edge.
- That's what I have--
- That scares me.
- I have that fear whenever
I stand on the platform edge
in Japanese...
Trains.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Because I've seen enough anime
where the main character gets shoved off
and there's nothing they
can do and I feel that,
so whenever I'm like standing
on the edge of a platform,
I literally have to stand
at a 90 degree angle
because otherwise, I
just feel uncomfortable.
I feel like someone could push me--
- Cause it's harder to
push this way, right?
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
At least if someone tries
to push me on the side
I can like try to stop the momentum,
but that's literally nothing I can do.
- I don't walk
cause like normally the
platform is so full, right?
And people don't stand on the yellow part
which is like the danger zone,
but like, if I need to
get to the other side,
I'll walk on the danger zone,
but I won't walk there
if the train's coming.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Because I'm like, I'm
not risking being nudged
or something, but if there's no train,
if I get pushed on the
tracks, I'll just get back up.
Someone will grab me around.
- I don't know man.
I've seen someone get, like
falling onto the tracks before.
- Oh really?
- Yeah.
- What happened, did people help him?
- I mean obviously like,
they have those like emergency buttons
that alerts everybody, so
like I think it was obviously
like some drunk dude
just out of his mind
trying to like get on.
- I think there's posters all
around the Japanese stations
being like, oh don't
get drunk, don't fall--
- I think it's something like 60 to 70%
of people who fall into the tracks
usually because they're drunk.
Which makes sense, but
yeah, I saw some dude
like kind of stumble around
and I was like, oh God,
this guy is getting
pretty close to the edge
and then sure enough, he just went.
- Oh wait, there was someone
at our station one time.
I remember seeing that.
- Oh really?
- Yeah, cause there was a
bunch of stretchers and stuff,
unfortunately, they fell and
hit their head pretty bad.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- Well, that's the thing, right?
It's like--
- The gap is big.
- It's really deep.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, so if you're not
careful, you can hurt yourself
even if there's no train coming, but yeah.
Do you guys have this like
a unfounded, like feeling
or fear or whatever,
whenever you see like a
big red emergency button
that you shouldn't press
and your mind's like,
what if I press that?
(Joey laughing)
- What?
No, I don't get that.
- I totally get that, yeah.
Like every time like you would go through
the school hallways, there'd
be like the fire alarm button.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Every time I would just
stop and look at and be like,
God, I wanna press this.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I've never gotten this urge.
- Because it's like I
feel that's an experience
that only like the 0.1% of kids you knew
ever got to experience it, like--
- Well, you just wanna press the button?
- Yeah, why you wanna press the button?
- That was almost a
bragging right as a kid,
I feel being like, yeah, I've
pressed this button before.
We like, well, how was it?
It's like, of course it's
like pressing any button.
- Cause I don't know what
the emergency buttons
or the fire alarm buttons
you had in your school,
but in like British School or my school,
we had like this, it wasn't a button,
it was like a very thin piece of glass
that you have to break
and I always wondered,
what does it feel like to
break that piece of glass?
Like I just wanna know.
I just wanna know what happens to that
if I break that piece of glass.
- Yeah, yeah, it's like
what does it feel like?
Like it does it hurt?
Is it hard?
- Like how thin is it?
How much force would it
take to press this button?
- I do think, when you're
on a bus sometimes,
you see that little puny little hammer.
- Yeah, yeah.
- There'll be like this giant window,
there'll be this tiny little like,
it looks like an ice pick and a tiny--
- That's another one.
Every time I came back from school
and I saw that little hammer,
I was like, I wanna use that.
- I think what happens
is when you literally that
thing like touches your thing,
it just shutters.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I was on a bus one time
when the windows exploded.
- Really?
- Yeah, so what happened was,
I was near the back of the bus
and it was our university
and it was a varsity event,
so they drove the bus to the
like one hour university over
from Sandy to Cardiff.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And when we were on our way back,
the bus driver went down the wrong road.
Now, as you put it, you
are aware, roads in the UK.
If you don't go on the
right one with a bus,
it's way too narrow.
- All right, right.
- Yeah.
- So what happened was, is that
he went down the wrong road
and he had to turn around,
but it was like the road
was like this, right?
It's like a three-point, like--
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- So we went down this way and
so he backed it up the hill
to try and turn around and as
he was trying to swing the bus
back round, the house that was
in like the end of this road
had like a pointing out,
like a thing on the edge of that property.
Like a tile and so as the bus is turning,
you could see, I saw,
cause I was sitting here
like on this side and that was the side
where the window was, you could
just see this thing coming
and I think they were
like started screaming
when they saw it cause
he was getting real close
and it just went and
just exploded the window.
- Wow.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah and then the guy
obviously heard the fucking
shutter and was like, "Oh!"
So he backed up, goes
to try it again, boom!
Other window goes and there's
glass everywhere, but--
- Wait, was that like near
any of the students or?
- Yeah, but they all
ran to the other side.
- Oh, fucking hell.
- So like it was like, it was terrifying
and then the bus driver
didn't stop or anything.
He just like--
- I'ma try this again.
- He smashed I think in total
three of the big ass windows
on the side of the bus and then
just drove back like normal.
- Jesus Christ.
- I'm sitting here,
like glass everywhere, like what do I do?
- Did the glass explode on someone?
- Yeah, but the thing
is right on the windows,
it's common as you know this as well.
When they smash them into
their like the way they made,
the window smashed into like non sharp--
- They're like blunt, little--
- Then they're a little like bolts,
so they don't like cut anyone.
- Still, that's scary.
- It was fucking terrifying.
- So what happened afterwards?
- What happened was is that we just drove
the last 20 minutes with
no windows on the side
and then we got off and everyone
was like, what the fuck?
And we all went and was like,
what the fuck just happened?
And I'm sure that guy lost his job.
- Oh yeah, probably.
- No idea what happened.
University never said anything.
- How old were you guys?
- I was like 20.
- Oh, okay.
- Jesus.
- This like a university bus.
- This is my third year of university
and I was like, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
And I just went on with my day.
I was like, that was weird.
- Jesus Christ.
- Yeah, never heard anything about that.
Felt like I deserved an
apology for having glass
flash on my face.
- Was it loud?
- Dude, yes!
You ever had glass explode?
- No I haven't.
(all giggling)
- I have had like probably
the loudest sound I ever heard
was, have you guys ever
had like lightning strikes
like hit really close?
- Yeah.
- To were you are?
- No, actually, no.
- Like you could feel the
shockwave at that point.
- So I had one moment where like,
I legitimately thought I was gonna die,
but it was in high school and like L,
the front part of our school
has this like big courtyard
looking thing and it's
kind of on an uphill climb,
so if you're standing like
right at the top of the hill
and look up, you can basically look across
the entirety of the school,
which is kind of cool.
So then me and my couple
of my friends were there
and it was like very lightly raining
and you can hear thunder
off in the distance,
but it wasn't like a thunderstorm, right?
So everybody was outside
just kind of chilling
and we had this like one
really massive pine tree.
I wanna say it's maybe like
15, 20-meter tall pine tree.
It's huge, just like on the
other side of the school.
- Right.
- And I was looking at it for some reason,
just kind of like waiting
for the bus, just like--
- What a beautiful pine tree.
- Yeah, no, no, because it's so massive
that it basically just
fills up your entire view
and then all of a sudden
it was just this like flash
of white and this the largest
fucking crashing sound
I've ever fucking heard
and what turned out
was a lightning bolt had
struck that pine tree
and that pine tree was probably
only about like 20 meters
away from me.
- Oh, wow.
- But it was fucking massive
and it was crazy as well
because like we're at the top of the hill,
so you can see all the other
students across the courtyard
and everybody simultaneously
was like, like that.
- Obviously, I think I'd shit myself.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But it was so weird because
that entire crash happened
and for like 20 seconds
the entire courtyard
was just silent and we're
kind of just like standing
and then fucking seventh grader,
like kids whose balls haven't dropped,
you all over sudden like, "Aaah!"
- This girl fucking
shell shocked and PTST?
- And there was just this
fucking panic across the school.
All the teachers like shitting themselves.
The tree was on fire.
- Yeah.
- So like straight up,
it was just like a fire,
like this 20-meter tall
pine tree was just on fire.
- That was satanic shit.
- But it was crazy because
it was like it from, I'd say
between a five minute span,
no, sorry, five seconds span,
it went from beautiful large
pine tree to just a burning
20-meter log.
- Darn, bro.
- It's fucking crazy.
- Darn
This episode is sponsored by Honey.
- Guys, listen, we all shop online
and we've all seen the
promo code field torn to us
us at the checkout, but thanks to Honey,
manually searching for coupon codes
is a thing of the past gentlemen.
Imagine it.
- I am.
- You're shopping on one
of your favorite sites.
- I can see it.
(all giggling)
- Keep going, keep going.
- When you check out the
Honey button drops down
and all you have to do is click.
- Oh my God.
- Apply coupons.
- Wait a few seconds is
Honey searches for coupons
it can find for that site.
- My God keep going.
- If Honey finds a working coupon,
you'll watch the prices drop.
- Oh my God.
- Gentlemen, I gotta know, what
did Honey save you money on?
- Pizza.
- No way, get outta here.
- Clothes.
- Are you kidding me?
That's practically
everything in the industry.
- Everything you can think of,
Honey can save you money on.
- Gentlemen, I gotta ask,
how much should you save using Honey?
- About 20 bucks.
- On what?
- On pizza.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, because pizza
in Japan is expensive.
- Yeah, I mean, I would take any save.
- Yeah, I could buy a whole lot of pizza--
- Garnt, what about you?
- I saved 15 bucks on online
delivery for my clothes.
- Wow, I saved $15 on a new boom mic.
- Ooh
- But did you know gentlemen
that Honey has found
it's over 17 million members
over $2 billion
in savings.
- Get out of here, Mr. Beast,
we found a new king of YouTube.
- If you don't have Honey already,
I will come to your house
and install it for you,
but you could also be straight up
missing out on free savings.
It's literally free and
installs in just a few seconds.
- And by getting it, you'll
be doing yourself a solid
and you'll be doing the
boys a solid as well
by supporting this podcast.
- So get Honey for free right now
at joinHoney.com/trashtaste.
That's joinHoney.com/trashtaste.
- Back to the episode.
- It really was scary.
I mean, again like that was probably,
I thought I was gonna go deaf
cause it was so fucking loud.
It was insanely the other loudest sound
I've ever heard was--
- Clap my ass chick.
- Yeah, that's it, of course
you can't escape from me snake,
but the other one was,
we were playing cricket.
- Of course, as the--
- Just give me some anime shit.
- We were playing cricket
and have you ever felt
like how hard a cricket ball is?
- Yeah, I think I do.
- Yes, yeah.
- That thing is fucking hard,
it's like a rock basically.
Yeah, it is a solid
piece of whatever it is,
but we were playing cricket in school
and I was in the outfield
and one of the kids
like kind of smacked it really,
really high up into the air
and it was going towards one of my friends
and he was underneath,
he was ready to catch it.
He was like, "Come on, catch
it, catch it, catch it,"
but I think he miss timed it
because the sun was in his eyes
or something, so the cricket ball
landed right in his forehead.
- Ooh, God!
- And the only way I
can describe the sound
was as if someone in the distance
had slapped two pieces of wood together.
It was just like this clack sound
and the kid just dropped to the floor.
We straight up thought he died.
Cause he just--
- That shit is hard bro.
- Yeah.
- Was that like the Mortal
Kombat moment where.
(all murmuring)
It's like a fucking fatality.
- Yeah, honestly, because it
went crack on his forehead
and he literally just
dropped to the floor.
- Right.
- Was he okay?
- He was fine, like he
had like a massive bruise
on his head, but he--
- Man, this man's got a dummy thick skull.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
We straight up thought he
had died, we were like,
Oh my God.
- The hardest I've ever hit my head,
this is gonna be a strange story.
So I was in sex ed.
- Okay.
- Let me tell the story all, right?
It was I think second
or third class of sex education, right?
So you know how it is,
teachers wanna seem cool.
- How old are you at this point?
- Like 13.
- Okay.
- So teachers like that,
we wanna seem cool.
This one, yes, he's sitting at the table
some watching the video.
I don't know why, is it a universal rule
where the tables in the science class
are taller than the ones
in the other classes?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You have that as well?
- Cause you have like stools.
- Yeah, it's like stools,
like marge, right?
So it's a pretty large table
and we're sitting on it
and so we were watching this
and when we were all on the
table, all sitting together
with the boys watching the sex
ed and the girls obviously.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And on this day I decided
that I was going to forego breakfast.
I thought I don't need
a breakfast, I'm a king,
I'm gonna go to my sex education mother
and I'm gonna watch it and
I don't need no breakfast.
So I was feeling a little queasy,
but I was like it's okay, it's okay.
- You're feeling queasy
watching the video?
- I was feeling queasy before
and then I felt even more
queasy hearing about this stuff
because I was 13, they were like,
yeah, so goo comes out
of the woman's thing
and I'm like.
(Joey and Garnt giggling)
All right, so I'm sitting
there and I'm like,
all right, okay, okay and
then I'm suddenly like,
I just started feeling like, oh, whoa,
stuff's getting blurry and
then I fall on my friend
next to me, right?
And my friend thinks classic Connor,
classic Connor fucking around, isn't it?
So he just shrugs me off.
(all laughing)
And so I go from this like
pretty high tall table,
like fell on my friend.
I just dunk my head on this
like pure like concrete floor.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And I wake up and I come to
and I just hit like screaming
and I'm like, what the fuck?
And I look around and all
the kids have like ran
to the other side of the room
and I'm just waiting here
like, what the fuck's going on?
I can't see shit, cause
like my eyes are so blurry,
so I hit my head so hard and
I'm like, oh, what's going on?
Like, I'm literally, I remember I sit up
and I'm like, what's happening?
- Yeah, you initially
fainted from a sex ed.
- Yeah, I got so much shit
for it as well obviously.
- That's such an anime moment.
- I know, right?
Yeah and obviously in school I was like,
"Ah, Connor fainted cause he saw a dick."
(all laughing)
That's when I started fighting.
I'm kidding though and so I
couldn't see for like two hours.
Vision was blurry and I
was like, fuck, am I blind?
But then luckily it came through
and I think I was just
very heavily concussed.
- You're blinded by the dick.
- Blinded by, they was showing
Johnny sins his first wo--
- It's like, oh God.
- Well, that's like a death
sentence in school man.
- It was okay.
- Okay.
- So now you know, not to skip breakfast.
- Yeah, that was my bad cause yeah,
I often felt pretty
fucking sick all the time.
So yeah it was my bad.
- I mean, they just didn't help.
- I know, just hearing all
this stuff at that age,
I was like fuck, that sounds disgusting.
I hate like slime and goo so much,
so hearing it come out of like body parts
makes me feel so gross...
Yeah.
- It's the way they phrase it too, right?
Because the only thing I remember
from my sex education thing,
cause I think I was like 11
or 12 when I do the first
sex education thing.
So already it's like, argh,
for a lot of kids, right?
But like the only thing
I remember they told us
which is the only reason I remember
is cause it's so fucking
weird to this day,
but it was dead ass the first thing
the sex education teacher
said she was like,
"Okay everybody, get your index finger
"and put it on the inside of your mouth
"and feel your cheeks"
and I was like, okay, then that's like
"That's what the inside
of the vagina feels."
- Oh!
That's so cruel.
- And all the girls are like, "Oh!"
And all the guys are
like," Oh, hell yeah!"
(all laughing)
- Well you were to it, you
went to an all guys school.
- No, no, no, no, this
is in elementary school.
- Oh.
- Elementary school, right?
- Darn, that's the only thing I remember.
- I just don't remember what
it was that like set me off
and it was like, I don't know
why the fuck they showed this.
- Yeah.
- All right.
- But they were talking about,
I this is way too much information.
So here's a timestamp on screen
where we skipped talking about this stuff,
so go and sketch it,
maybe it's kind of likely
to leave the room, so they
were talking about discharge.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- For girls, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And it wasn't enough
to just talk about it.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- They had this like
reenactment of this girl
who goes to the toilet
and they dead asked to do a
closeup shot of like white shit
on her pants and I'm
like, that's disgusting.
Why would you show that?
We're like 13.
That's what like made me feel gross.
- Did you have to watch the obligatory,
like woman giving birth?
- Yeah, I was gonna talk about that
cause I swear to God,
whoever was like editing--
- That was like on a
British TV there as well.
They showed births.
- You serious?
- Yeah, there's a whole TV show.
- Well, you had like specialists videos
that schools like bought to show us like--
- It's fucking awful.
That's so graphic.
- Yeah and I mean, the person
who edited like our video,
they must have known what
they were doing, right?
Okay, so this guy,
this old British guy
was basically describing
the process of a baby coming
out of a vagina, right?
And so what they use to
describe what happens,
the process of this happening,
is they take a rubber band, right?
He takes a rubber band and
just like, he just goes,
imagine this is the hole
in the vagina, right?
This is what happened
when a baby comes out
and he literally stretches it like that
and then the class goes, "Oh,"
and shit you know, they
then hard cut to like a baby
that's just like crowning
and just like coming out
and I'm just like, thinking
back to that moment
and I'm just like, I
think like in the moment,
I'm just like the fucking editor
knew what he was doing there.
- It's not even like a cross
dissolve, it's just a hard cut.
- It's just a straight up hard guy.
He knew exactly what he was doing.
- Just like one of those
like, whooshes in like that,
just a fucking baby's head.
(all laughing)
God, they were so disgusting.
I mean, obviously I'm glad
that I was taught this stuff,
but at the same time did they
gotta go in so goddamn hard
on that shit, that like eases in.
- It was brutal.
- No one enjoyed it.
- [Connor] No, no.
- No one was like, "Oh,
this is interesting."
Everyone's like, "No, oh fuck!"
- I feel like it's a thing
that does need to happen though cause--
- Yeah, obviously I'm glad that I taught
cause I speak to Americans
and sometimes they're like,
"I have no sex education at all."
- Yeah, I mean, like Sydney
learned her sex education
through her toy and I mean--
- That's boring.
- That is boring.
- That's like, what is it like?
A lot of the States they
just say, "Oh, abstinent.
Wait until marriage."
That's legitimately like I
think many of the States--
- And I think it depends on the States.
- It's not mandatory or something?
- No, no, no.
- Oh , really, wow!
- In many States, the only
certification is abstinence.
Promote abstinence.
- Yes.
- So like Christian
school, so it's not like.
I think in England you have to do it,
but you have to teach it by law, right?
- Yeah, so in every, I think
like in age 13 gets taught,
like how to put on a condom,
how to do all that shit.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- How did you get towards,
did you get like the fucking banana?
(all laughing)
- No, it was so embarrassing.
This woman, right?
She was like, have you
seen "Matilda" that movie?
Like what's that woman called?
Like the devil teacher in that,
literally the woman looked
like that, dead ass.
- [Joey] Okay.
- Took out this like
fucking 12-inch dildo,
smacked it on the table and she was like,
who wants to put a condom on this?
Who wants to try?
And then everyone was
like, "What the fuck?"
Why is it so big?
(all laughing)
- A fucking dead ass dildo.
- It was massive.
It was huge.
- So, I got this from my own collection.
- That was why like, I
remember, I went home that day
and I'm like, what is average dick size?
Cause I was like, that cannot be normal.
That is like, that is 12 inches.
The girth of it was ridiculous.
That was clearly her own
personal one that she brought in.
- Yeah, had to there and there.
- Jesus Christ.
- Yeah, I have to do the banana.
- Yeah, I thought that was
just industry standard.
- Yeah.
- Oh, she put it, maybe there
was a banana and she was like,
"No, I'm gonna bring my own."
- Let me just bring my Aunt Summer's
like fucking pussy pleasure.
(all laughing)
- Dragon dildo.
- Cause I think what happened
was they ended up teaching it,
like we had so much of
it cause where I grew up
was like the worst place in
the UK for teen pregnancies.
There's so many, there's
so many that happened
where I grew up and it was, yeah,
obviously the government was like,
"Hey guys, we know you're gonna do it.
"Just please, please don't have babies."
- Yeah.
Just do it properly.
- At the right time.
- Remember like a few weeks ago
when I was talking
about how my mum told me
that babies came out of the belly button?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So like she watched the
episode and she messages me
the day afterwards reminding me
that actually my very first sex ed class,
which was in primary school.
I can't remember how old
I was, I think I was--
- I'd have sex in
primary, I don't think so.
- I think I had like a very early sex ed.
- Yeah, yeah
- I had two or three during
my entire childhood, I think
and it just like every sex
I'd got like progressively more graphic
Like the older you get
which is how it should be,
but she reminded me that the first time
I learned that babies didn't
come out of the belly button
and came out of the vagina.
I dead ass didn't believe them.
(all laughing)
- I came home and I
remember this so vividly
because I remember the very
first time I tried lying
to my mum and it was like such
an innocent little kid lie
where I went to the toilet
and I didn't wash my hands
and she asked me if I wash
my hands and I said, yes.
That was the first time I
attempted a lie in my life.
It was like the most vanilla
lie and she was like,
"Let me smell your hands.
"Let me smell your hands."
And I'm like, oh shit.
But the first time I
tried lying, I got caught,
so that was embedded in me
from like a very early age
just like people don't lie
cause people get caught
when they lie.
- Let me smell your hands.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, so you believed your mum.
- Yeah, so my mum's like,
"All right, I won't punish you this time,
"but let's just make a promise
"that we're just not going
to lie to each other ever."
And I like me, bright-eyed
like, five-year-old,
I believed her until
like I hit teenage hood.
So I go to this class and
people and their teachers
were telling us how babies
came out of the vagina
and I'm just like, actually.
(all laughing)
- Actually miss, I believe
that they actually come
out of the belly button.
I know this, my mom taught me
- Oh no.
- And she was trying to console me,
"No, they come out down there, your mom--"
- I'm sorry your mother is a liar.
- "I'm sorry your mom is wrong,"
so me being like the eight or 10-year-old,
I'm like, okay, there're
two adults in my life
that have said two different
pieces of information.
I go back to my home.
I go back and I tell my mom,
mom, the teacher taught me this.
She said, "You are a
liar," but you know what?
You promise me that we
wouldn't lie to each other.
So I believe you.
I believe you, mother.
I know that babies come
out of the belly button
and it's just like.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- Yaiks!
- And yeah, she just reminded
me that, that was a thing.
I can't actually remember when I realized
that babies didn't come
out of the belly button.
Message, just blanked that out.
Oh yes, thank you mother for
lying to me from a young age,
I know you're a liar now.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I remember one time I had
like a bit of hair sticking up
and for some reason when
I put like water in it,
it didn't go down.
- [Garnt] All right.
- That's like, fuck, that's real annoying
and I'm like 10 years old and I'm like,
I'm just gonna cut it.
It's in the way, because
it wouldn't go down.
So I cut like a chunk of my hair out
and then my mom's like,
"Connor, did you cut your hair?"
I'm like, no, no mother, of
course I didn't cut my hair.
She was like, "There's a piece missing."
I'm like, I think it
got trapped in the door.
It was all I said.
(all laughing)
She's like, "So you're
telling me that it got stuck
"in the door with enough force
"that it pulled your hair out?"
And I was like, of
course, as if she's like,
"Let's try it again."
(all laughing)
And I'm like, God, no.
I've never prayed for more of my life
that my hair gets ripped out.
(all laughing)
So you go to the door, the
hinge, first of all, she's like,
"How did you get your head
in the hinge at the end"
and I'm like, I have no idea about that.
So I put my hair in
the door and I close it
and of course, no hair
falls out and she's like,
"What happened Connor?"
And then she's like, okay, mom, I cut it
cause it was annoying me.
She's like, "Why did you do that?"
I don't know, it didn't
go down with water.
That's what I normally do and she's like,
"Well, you didn't need to do that"
and I'm like, oh, okay, okay, shit!
- Mine started earlier when I
was like stolen, like nappies
and stuff like that, all right?
Yeah, yeah, like cause I had this really,
for some reason I had the
fear of sitting on the toilet.
For some reason.
Like, because I think it was like two
or three years old, right?
It's like the last stage
of you still wearing nappies, right?
- Yeah.
- And like, I really hated taking a shit.
(Garnt laughing)
Like I was really scared
and I think it's because,
I think my mom explained it to me later,
she was like, "I think you were scared
"not to like actually sit on the toilet,
"but to like flush the toilet
"because you thought
"you were gonna get sucked in as well."
- I mean, not gonna lie,
there's those airplanes toilets.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Oh shit, oh my--
- It's the airplane toilet fear
and I thought that same force
was in my home toilet as well.
- I had the same fear.
I just fucking remembered this
and it came from an airplane.
Cause when you flush the airplane,
it feels like you're gonna get like sucked
into oblivion now.
- When I was like 10, what I would do
is I would like, fucking close the door,
cause you had like two
seconds, you pressed the button
and it goes two seconds.
Yeah, yeah, so you have
like two seconds to get out.
- So, I thought I had
that in my home toilet.
So at that point, so
two, three-year-old me
was just like I figured out of
resolution, just don't shit.
(Connor and Garnt laughing)
I'm wearing nappies.
- Isn't that like a South Park plot?
- It's like I'm wearing
nappies, just don't shit,
but like at that stage
as well, I was like,
I was too embarrassed
to admit to my parents
that I literally just shat in my nappies.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- So what I would do is like
I would hide behind the couch
and kind of just like subtly
do it behind the couch.
(all laughing)
While my parents weren't looking.
- What the fuck!
- And my mom would like
walk into the living room
and be like, "Joey, what are you doing?"
- I would try and get a refund on the kid
if they were doing that.
- It's like, "Joey, what are you doing?"
And I'm just like nothing and she's like,
"You're pooping, aren't you?"
And I'm like, no.
(Garnt laughing)
Me while my face is straining like.
(all laughing)
And my mom's like,
"I could literally smell
the shit from here."
(all laughing)
What are you talking about?
"Go to the fucking toilet."
- Oh my God.
- And I would literally
do that for like the longest
time until like finally,
you get to the stage
where you have to get
out of nappies, right?
And so I'm just like for the first like--
- You prolonged as much as you could.
- Yeah, for the first,
like two or three months
out of nappies, I dreaded
having to take a shit.
I'm like, oh, I have
to like psych myself up
and be like all right, I'm
not gonna get sucked in today.
You can do it.
(all giggling)
It was horrible.
- Man.
- Honestly, I still have,
like, I still have a fear
of going to the toilet on airplanes,
just because of that noise.
Like if, if I need to--
- But don't mind, shit's not pleasant.
- It's not pleasant, yeah.
- It's like, I just get
like a small flashback
every time I hear that noise.
I need to wear like
fucking thick headphones
every time I go, man.
I'm turning that music.
- Bro, that's what noise
canceling headphones
weren't built to feel like.
- I feel like, cause you were saying
that you didn't you'd never like lie,
we've never like lying
like your whole life
up to like 14, whatever?
Like when did you realize you could lie?
- I think it was when I
realized my parents lied to me
and I'm just like, I can't believe
they've bamboozled me like this
- I just realized it and I was like,
oh, I pretty started to like lie
a lot more for a younger
age because I had brothers.
- Yeah.
- Right, right.
- Because like you can't
lie to your parents
cause they're your parents, right?
They own you.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You don't get to like talk back.
- Yeah, cause I didn't
lie to my fucking parents.
Like I said, like I got caught
the first time I attempted
this, so after that I was like,
this is a loser's game.
I'm gonna lose when I try.
- For me, it was like, when
you'd like go visit a friend
or something and you'd like,
the friend would be like,
"Oh, I'm just gonna say to
my parents that we're here
"to do homework or whatever,
but we'll just go to my room
"and play games" and I was
like, no, that's not gonna work.
My parents would immediately
see through that shit
and I would see my
friend, Dwayne being like,
"Yeah, we're just gonna do homework"
and the parents like, "Okay."
I'm just like, you can do that?
Oh my God.
I'm gonna do that from now on.
- Yeah, I think cause you
only have like siblings.
I don't know, I feel like
you end up having to lie
cause you're always fighting and arguing--
- Right and but like I
was such a terrible thing
cause you have older brothers, right?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, cause I was the oldest
in the family, so I had
to like teach my sister
to be like, listen, you
can lie to the parents.
I've seen it happen, I've
done it before, she's like,
"Oh my God, thank you brother."
- Parents hate this one
trick, but people know it.
(all laughing)
- Oh my God.
- Obviously.
- Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I didn't like to
me learning I could lie
or learning that people was
like watching that like,
one life hack, YouTube video
that was literally an actual life.
That was actually a literal high-life act.
- Oh my God.
- But no, I feel like
that's why some people
were just like so bad at lying
because sometimes you
play a game of Among Us.
You can tell who the good
lies from the bad lies are.
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I think I've always had
this fear, like ingrains me
from a kid that I shouldn't
lie and even as an adult
I have a harder time lying
than some other people.
- That's right, that's
why I hate playing games
like Among Us and like
Werewolf or shit like that,
cause I just can't lie.
- Yeah, but it isn't
fun place to just like,
just have like a safe space
where you can all just fucking lie
and like laugh at each other--
- No, because I'm like,
I can't trust any of you motherfuckers--
- Why?
What, no!
- Like after this game is over,
I don't think I'll be able
to believe anything you say.
- Cause it's fun, right?
Cause it's like you get to experience
what it'd be like being interrogated
if you committed like
murderer or something.
- Why was that fun?
- I don't know, it's fun
seeing if you can lie,
if you can bullshit your
way out of it, I don't know.
- But you can never
bullshit your way out of it.
We should know this.
- Sometimes.
- That's why it's fun to
watch interrogation videos.
- Yeah.
- Well, they are naturally be--
- I'm glad I'm not that guy right now.
- [Connor] Yeah, true.
- It's like the reason
why I watch Leaguey Sports
rather than actually wanting
to play League myself.
It's funny to watch other
people go through pain
rather than to have it hit myself.
That's a really weird tangent,
but that's the closest
person I could think of.
- I like seeing people suffer, not me.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- I mean, who doesn't.
- Oh, I think the reason
why mangas did so good
is cause it did give like a
thing where you can be like,
"Hey man, there's not many games out there
"where you can just like lie"
and that's the whole game.
It's like lying and
deceiving and that's fun
to get to do that and like
blow off some steam doing it.
- Yeah, I definitely do enjoy it.
I've played like plenty
of games of Werewolf
where I really enjoyed that.
Among Us, I just didn't
get to play enough games
to really get used to it
cause I was still at the stage
where they'd ask me what I was doing,
I was like, I don't know
what else I was doing.
- I'm following the map.
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
- I like those games, it was
fun when you would like realize
after like one or two rounds, you're like,
I know who the gut liar is.
- Yeah.
- Gotta take em' out.
So they don't get to lie.
- I'd say I never got to
that stage because in my head
I'm just like, how am I gonna
bullshit my way out of this?
- Yeah, by the time I had
started playing Among Us,
there was already a fucking meteor.
- It's like, what task were you doing?
And so-and-so okay, I know your innocent.
- Like I just, I was getting smirked on.
- I really enjoyed it,
but I think after like the first two weeks
the novelty really walled off on me,
but obviously it didn't on YouTube
cause it was like, it had like,
well, like four, five months?
- Entire career is what
created from that game.
- Yeah, I haven't seen
anything blow up that much
in a long time.
It's got crazy.
- I don't know.
- I mean, I feel like I started
watching Twitch contents
way more after Among Us and four guys
really took off last year
and before that I had
I'd hardly had watched
any Twitch streamers at all
and the only live streams
I watch was like VTubers back then,
but I was mostly on YouTube.
So it kind of really, I feel like,
I don't know if it's just me,
but I like Twitch streamers is
like way bigger personalities
than they were in 2019.
I don't know if that's
just my perspective,
but I definitely see a lot
more Twitch people now.
- I think at least, pretty
cause were on YouTube, right?
And I think what has happened
is that Twitch Streamers,
their content that's being put on YouTube
is doing much better than before.
- [Garnt] Right, right.
- I think it's before the
biggest channels would get
maybe 100,000, 200,000 views
if they air that videos,
they upload it, but now the Among Us clips
are getting like five, six,
seven, 12, million views
and it's like wow, that is nuts.
- Well, I think it's
because I still don't watch
as much Twitch, but I see so
many clips on my recommended
and on my YouTube feed.
I can't not see it now
and I'm way more aware of what's going on
even though I hardly
actually watched Twitch.
- Yeah, I don't know, I'm
really enjoying it right now.
I'm really enjoying streaming so much.
I don't know.
- And you've been playing
like Apex every day.
- Yeah, I'm gonna take Apex man, so much.
- You found your new addiction?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I have.
- You're just gonna end up
being like an Apex streamer.
- Probably--
- Full time, yeah.
I don't know, I feel like,
cause right now what it is
is that I just wanna play
this game and I'm just like,
all right, I just happened
to put the stream on as well.
- You see, like I can't do that
because like my not stream gaming mode
and my stream gaming mode is
like completely different.
- I agree, same thing here.
- In my head I'm just like,
if I'm not constantly
commentating while I'm streaming,
then I'm gonna look boring
whereas if I'm off stream,
I am fucking silent for six hours.
- Yeah, me too, me too.
- Yeah.
I mean like, when you're getting filmed,
I had to like really force
like comments out of myself,
but that's how I feel with Twitch as well
where sometimes I'm playing
a game in Twitch mode,
sometimes I feel like
I have to force myself
to say something.
This isn't like my natural default self.
- I don't think that's normal though.
Like no one normally just talks
while they're playing
video games themselves.
Let's say that you actively learn to--
- Yeah, but I feel like sometimes
you think at least, right?
Or you, I don't know.
- Actually, in some video games,
I don't verbalize any of my thoughts,
even it might mentally
cause you can like mentally
verbalize your thoughts,
but I don't even do that.
I'm just like, I'm playing the game,
and it's just all like instincts.
- I only got used to it
because I used to do
let's plays on my channel,
but like before that,
like my first couple--
- Why did you do the let's plays?
- Yeah, my first couple lets
plays, I was boring as hell
just cause I was at that
stage where I was like,
okay I have to say something.
I can't just like keep
advancing with the game silently
because I'm on camera,
but as I did it for
like fucking three years
or however long it was, I just
kind of learned to be like,
here's something that I can
say, here's something I can say
to the point where I
found myself sometimes
in my non-recording gaming
sessions, commenting to myself
and I'm just like, oh
no, this is a problem.
It's like 2:00 a.m and I'm
playing Final Fantasy 13
and I'm commenting to myself.
- Commentating to yourself?
- Are you streaming sharing?
No, Why?
- No, cause I was still
living in my parents
back in the time
and so my parents would
come in being like,
"Who are you talking to?"
And I'm just like, oh my
God, who am I talking to?
There's no camera rolling.
I'm not recording this.
- My parents thought I was,
cause I was always on X-Box
voice chat talking to people,
they thought when I started
voice acting they were like,
"Oh Connor's just talking
to his friends on X-Box."
So they didn't know what I was doing.
- He's just talking in funny voices.
- I said, "Why is he saying the same thing
"over and over again, huh?
"Doing different inflections.
"That's really fucking weird.
"Nevermind, he's probably playing X-Box,
"Connor's a weird one."
(all laughing)
- You got some weird hobbies, right?
- Yeah, I think my parents
definitely when I was kid,
they saw me as like the weird kid
of like the four, they were like,
"He's the strange one,
"but normally things work out in the end."
- He'll find his way.
- Yeah, that's normally the way it was.
- I mean, like growing
up, sometimes I do wish
that I did have brothers and sisters
cause I feel like, I
dunno how you guys feel
about your siblings, but I
feel like there's nothing--
- I wouldn't wanna be raised
without brothers or sisters,
I think now that I've had them,
I just couldn't imagine not
being raised with siblings.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, same.
- I don't know.
- I can't imagine just having
to share everything though.
That's--
- Well, you don't have to.
- That's how you learn to lie, right?
(all laughing)
Although I did have to share
my X-Box and that was horrible.
We have to like swap
every hour and I'm like,
I can't even get a good gaming
session in here for now,
are you kidding me?
- I mean, that's why I'm glad
like the first like game console we got
was Game Boy Advances
cause we had one each.
- That was the first console you got?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well yeah, like any console
that we could actually share, right?
Or wasn't like a, two-play thing
cause we had like the N64,
I used to like that too,
but if you have two controllers
you can play together,
but can't quite do that on a
on a handheld console, right?
- [Connor] True, true.
- So it was fucking fun.
Like sometimes I'd wanna get on the N64,
play a one-player game,
like fucking Donkey Kong 64
or Super Mario 64 or something.
You can't play that with my sister.
- Yeah.
- So I was like fuck,
what do we do?
Let's get a handheld console
and just play whatever fuck
the games we want together.
Problem solved.
- Man, I miss being stupid
as a kid and I do because--
- I had this thought the other
day, I miss how simple it was
just to like find happiness in something.
- Right, so my first game--
- Getting real deep here.
- Sorry, my first game
console or game device
was a Game Boy Color.
- Okay.
- Right?
And my parents bought it for me in France
and they were like,
"What games do you want?"
I'm like Pokemon.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I didn't know at the time.
- So it says that the game
is in French obviously
cause we're in France,
but somehow still managed
to complete the whole thing.
- [Joey] Wow!
- When I was like eight
or something and I'm like, I
would not have the patience
to fucking do that now.
- No, no.
- No, I don't know what
the fuck was going on.
I don't know what any of the moves did,
but I think like eight-year-old
me had just understood
that this set of letters
did this funny thing
that did a lot of damage
cause I had just been playing it so much.
So I think by the time
I got to the elite four,
I think nearly all my
Pokemon were level a 100.
- Oh my God.
- That was literally just
trial by fire, right?
- It was literally just
grinding and I'm like,
how the fuck did I do that?
I'm so dumb or at least being that dumb
where I could just throw
myself at something like that.
- Yeah, like I remember cause I also,
I mean I got the Game Boy Advance,
but the first couple of games
I got were Game Boy Color games
because you could play
the Game Boy Color games
in the Game Boy Advance which I was like,
Oh my God, technology,
but I remember like the part
where I think about it now
where it's like, I definitely
had too much time as a kid
that I could not sink into my adulthood
was when I managed to on my
Pokemon Sapphire cartridge.
I played it so much that I
maxed out the in time clock.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah, like I found out
that on Pokemon Sapphire
on Game Boy Advance.
- Is it 1,000 hours or--
- Yeah, 999 hours and 99 minutes
is the furthest it will go.
- Did you just leave this thing on 24/7?
- No, that's how much I played it.
- I see it, man.
When you're a kid, you just get obsessed.
- Like every moment,
because especially the Game Boy Advance,
like looking back on it now,
this thing's fucking tiny.
Well, you can put that
in like jeans pocket
or like a jacket pocket,
take it everywhere.
- The best one
cause I think it was
literally when we were kids
was that Game Boy Advance SP.
- Oh, yes, oh!
- Oh!
That was so good.
- Only the cool rich kids had a--
- Wow, the SP was like the best one
cause that like just
it would literally fit
in your tiny child jeans.
- Yeah.
- It was amazing.
- I remember one of my Japanese
friends brought it to school
once and he was like,
"Boys, check this out."
I was like, whoa and it was like,
"And it's got a backlight
on it" and I was like, whoa!
You can play that at night.
- Oh yeah, the backlight.
I completely forgot that
was the massive thing.
- The SP was the first
one that had a backlight
and before then you had to attach
like those like fucking reading lamp.
- The fucking reading
lights, like the awful glare.
- I think actually the
first model of the SP
didn't have a backlight.
It was like the second model
which is the more popular model I think.
- [Garnt] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- But I had an SP and I got
one cause my friend got one
and I saw him playing it and
for like Christmas I was like,
mom I want nothing more than
the Game Boy Advance SP.
You know what game I
played the most on it?
- What?
- Fucking GBA game.
I played Pokemon Trading Card Game.
Have you played that game on Game Boy?
- Yeah, yeah.
- It was so good.
- It was fucking great.
- I remember like, oh go ahead.
- Oh, sorry, sorry, I had a
finalization to this story.
One time I thought, I was so
addicted to this thing, right?
I would literally walk
around the house with it.
I would sleep with it.
- [Joey] Oh yeah, of
course, of course, yeah.
- If I was walking down the stairs
I would play Game Boy
walking down the stairs.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- If I was down at the
table, that'd be there,
if It was going to bed, I'd play it.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I would even if I went to
pee, I would play with it.
- [Garnt] Okay.
- So I would pee with it.
One time I dropped it down the toilet.
- No.
- Not sure how it happened, I was playing,
I was just playing
Pokemon Trading Card Game
and that was the cartridge that was there,
I was playing it while I was peeing.
You're like 12, your little
dick's out, you're like.
I don't know how I
dropped it, I dropped it
and I was like, how do I
explain this to my mom?
How do I tell her that I don't
have a Game Boy SP anymore?
(all laughing)
And yeah, it didn't work.
- Did you lie?
- No, cause it smelled of piss as well.
For some reason I checked
if the Pokemon Trading
Card Game still worked.
- Of course.
- But of course.
- So I plugged it into the
old Game Boy Color I had.
- Yeah.
- But yeah, so I had to go
to my mom, I was like mom,
so this is kind of like embarrassing.
I dropped my Game Boy down
the toilet and she was like,
"How did you drop your Game
Boy down the fucking toilet?"
And I'm like, I don't know.
I just really enjoy playing it
and my family fucking rinsed
me for like five years.
- Oh yeah, if that was my kid,
I'd fucking rinse him too.
- Do you know how expensive
a Game Boy Advance SP
is at that age?
- Yeah, but they loved it
purely for the comedic purposes.
Every time we'd meet someone,
they're like this is Callum.
He's very successful, very smart.
This is Connor, he dropped his Game Boy
down the fucking toilet.
(all giggling)
And I was so sad for like four months.
I was just like this on
every window, I was like
what do I do?
- Did you ever get another one?
- I did six months later for my birthday.
I was like,
- Wow, really?
Yean and literally I
remember like for six months
I was like playing Game Boy Color again,
just playing Pokemon Trading Card Game
with other shitty Game Boy--
- Your parents are nice man.
If I did that, my parents
would never buy me
a game cartridge.
- I think they felt so bad for me
because of how like distraught I was
and I think they thought
I was gonna get over it,
but I was sad for like half a year.
- Oh yeah, it's like dropping
a laptop down the toilet.
- I could not get over it
and I think my parents
at some point were like,
"All right, I think we
should get him another one
"or maybe like he's not gonna recover.
"Maybe he's never gonna let
this go" and I wouldn't have,
I wouldn't have let this go.
- Yeah, because like for me Game Boys
were the only game console
or like handheld consoles
that I could actually
get every game I wanted
and that's because every
year we'd visit our family
in Thailand and there's
always like that one store
that my parents would take me to
and it wasn't a legit Nintendo store.
- Really?
Really don't know.
- I don't know if you could tell,
but you basically go in the store
and they didn't have the game cartridges.
They would just have just the book
and you'd go for this book
and you tell these people
which games you wanted.
- Right, right.
- So like my entire life,
I would have to wait
like a fucking one year
to get two games.
One was for Christmas
and one's for my birthday
and that was like the N64.
Game Boy was like, this was
like the early steam sale.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I would just like the humble bumble.
- Was free will instead.
- Yeah, I would just go, I
would just go and come in
every year and be like, motherfucker,
I'm about to buy 15
games for like 10 bucks
or something like that.
I felt good.
- You don't like the
Chad like fucking like,
"I'll take everything
from here to here please."
(all laughing)
- Oh, it was such a good
childhood experience.
Just like to sit down
and just I would be
there for about two hours
and they would like, every game
would have a different code.
I would fill up like A4 piece
of paper with just codes.
I'm like mother, give me all these games
and I wouldn't even play all them games,
but it just felt good buying them.
I felt rich for once.
- It's because there was so many.
I don't know what it was
about the Game Boy Advance
where it was like didn't know
there was a game with that,
but there is on the Game Boy Advance.
- Yeah.
Well, I used to trade
games with the other kids.
- Oh, I did that too.
- Yeah.
- Just the games that I was done with
like Scooby-Doo Adventure, I'm pretty okay
knowing I won't play this again.
- If we go back to the lying thing,
I've lied to one of my friends--
(all laughing)
- What did you lie?
Why?
- So, I had this fucking
like Mickey Mouse game
on Game Boy Advance which I fucking hated.
I don't know where I got it.
- Did you hustle some kid?
Did you hustle some 12-year-old?
- I don't know where I got it from,
I think I got it from like
a cousin's hand me down
or something, right?
But it was like, it was in that
bundle of like two or three,
like shitty, like not known IP,
get why does this exist type
of Game Boy Advance games
that you get and one of
them was this Mickey Mouse
like fucking platform a game.
I don't even remember what
the fuck it was, but yeah,
I was in school and my friend was like,
"Oh I got the new," this
is when Emerald came out.
- Right.
- But side Ruby and
Sapphire at the time, right?
But I didn't have Emerald and I was like,
I really wanna play it.
- No, no!
- So I was like and his friend,
my friend wanted like
to play this other like,
I don't remember if it was
a Pokemon game or Mario game
or something, like one
of the main line games.
He's like, "I really wanna
play this" and I said,
y'all got that game.
(all laughing)
- No.
- So what I did was I had, the
thing is I did have the game,
but I didn't wanna give it to him.
- Yeah.
- But I had the box for it.
- No!
- So I did it.
- Mickey Mouse.
I fucking gebated him
and I slipped the Mickey
Mouse game into the Mario box
and I was like, here you go mate, inbox.
Don't have to check it,
now you can check it
when you get home, right?
And I took Emerald from him
and I still have that Emerald
cartridge to this day.
- Wait, did his mom not call
you out your mama who like,
be like, "What the fuck,
your kids scammed my kid."
- I don't know, maybe he really
liked the Mickey Mouse game.
- Cause in the UK, there was these like
you'd have like footballer cards.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- Right, right, right.
Like Fantasy Football?
(Connor murmuring)
- I don't know who was good.
I didn't care about football.
I just wanted the best stuff
cause I was like, it's a game,
I want the best and I
was a real hustler, man.
I would do deals, I'd be like
that stockbroker being like,
"I can give you this,
I can give you that."
"Maybe, I don't know"
and one time I remember,
I was really annoyed cause this one kid,
he did a really stupid trade
with me and I was like,
sucks to be human.
He gave me like one whole
DTO for like some two players
that were terrible and I
was like profit, stocks
and I went home, right?
I thought, great.
I'm looking at my collection of cards.
This is amazing, I've done
such great business today.
I was literally like Trump
out of the deal at school.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, making good trades
and I'm just chilling at
home, admiring my collection
and my mum comes in being like,
"Connor, what have you done?"
I'm like, what have I done?
She's like, "Tim's mom has called up.
"She's furious.
"You apparently you
stole a card from him."
I'm like I didn't steal a car from Tim.
Tim's a fucking liar.
Tim gave me Ronaldinho for
two of these shitty players.
She's like, "Really?"
And I'm like, yeah, yeah,
get him on the phone.
I'll tell him what happened.
And so I'm arguing with him
and he's like crying on
the phone, being like,
"That wasn't a fair
trade, you scammed me."
I'm like, I didn't scam you,
I don't know who's good.
I just saw that this game was
shiny and you gave it to me
and then I got fucking, I had
to apologize and give it back
cause he made a dumb trade.
I'm like, that kid got lucky.
- That doesn't happen
in the real world kid.
- Yeah.
- I'm like in the real world
that guy never would've
got his money back.
He deserved to take the other guy.
I was so pissed, I was like, mom,
you interfered in my negotiations.
Do you know how irresponsible that is?
That kid should have learned the hard way,
that he made a bad trade.
- Your mom literally did
like a CIA drug bust.
(all laughing)
- I was like--
- Doom, doom, doom, open the door!
- Even like 12-year-old me is like,
I think he should deal
with the consequences.
It was a bad deal.
- He agreed to it.
- He should learn now that this shit hurts
when you make a bad deal.
- He needs to learn a valuable lesson.
- Yeah.
He learned the hard way.
- Clearly, his mom is cuddling
him too much and helping him.
What is this?
Like the fucking Melvin capital?
Like the fucking the stock trade?
What's the American stock trade,
like people who watch the things being--
- I don't know.
- I don't fucking know that.
- Game stops getting out of hand.
We have to stop this, no, no, no.
They literally did that to me.
This is fucked up, terrible.
I was furious.
- I kind of like talking about this
is bringing back memories for me as well
cause the only time I've ever
liked tried to hustle people
was during like the Pokemon card era.
- Oh yeah.
- Yeah, I do.
- There was so much, I
think he just got normalized
that just kids would just
try to hustle each other.
- I'll give you a 100 energies for Ho-ho.
Please, please.
- I swear like around the world,
like we had the fucking like,
the big like cocaine thing
in the 80s, but like the 2,000
was like the Pokemon card
equivalent and like everyone was like,
"I'm gonna fucking scam
everybody for this."
- You don't know real hustle
man until you've been in school
trading Pokemon or pugs or
whatever the it is like.
I said, that's like, that's
where the real negotiations
happen, I'll tell you what?
That's where I learned
the art of the deal.
(all laughing)
- Cause like away from the streets.
- I lived the hard way.
- Cause like I remember when
I first getting into Pokemon,
I just had like the worst "Gacha" luck.
I was buying so many expansion
packs that I got nothing.
So I had like no value
that I could trade with.
So I'm just like, what can I scrounge up
that I could sell to people with value.
So going back to the the
old game game cartridges
that I would always buy.
- Right.
- So I knew, right?
Even as a kid, I knew
like those game cartridges
that you get that says 400
games in one game cartridge,
I would always buy them
and I'd tried playing them,
but you know, they would
have like the shitest games.
- And it's normally 30 games
or like 30 games that repeat.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it was like 30 games
from like a game that was
like a Chinese rip off
from like the older generation cartridge.
- And there's like
eight different versions
of Tetris on that.
- Yeah, so I'm just like, I
don't need these in my life.
I'ma try to sell them.
I'ma try to hustle
these for Pokemon cards.
So, because I got these
in like Southeast Asia,
I don't know what it
was like in your town,
but like you couldn't
really get like knockoff
game card cartridges or
knockoff game as well.
- I only ever like saw them
once and my mind was blown.
I was like, how the fuck did you get this?
- Yeah.
So I would go up to kids on the playground
and be like, yo, you
gotta Chinese Charles OD,
lemme let me introduce to
you to my game cartridges.
Yo, this game cartridge
says 30 games on it.
- Going as the recommended
retail price of one game.
That could be up to $10,000.
- So I basically pawned
off these cartridges
that I wasn't gonna play
for shiny Pokemon cards
and that's how I got like at one point
the most like shiny Pokemon
cards on the playground
and then I left three of them
in my life fucking jean pocket
in the wash and they were just gone.
- Oh no!
- Lost.
- I used to do something similar to that,
but with Yu-Gi-Oh cards,
cause Pokemon cards
got very quickly banned from my school
cause like all the kids would
just like, even during class
would just be fucking playing
around with it, right?
So we were like, all right,
well, the teachers already
know what a Charaza looks like.
- [Connor] Shit, they're
in it on the inside.
- But they don't know what blue eyes,
white dragon looks like.
- What part of greed looks like.
- So let's move on to Yu-Gi-Oh cards
and I got so into like the
hustling of Yu-Gi-Oh cards,
like to the point where
like it was the peak
of fucking Obelisk?
The fucking like, you collect
the five pieces of Obelisk
in your hand and you're
like automatically win
the game like that.
- Yeah yeah.
- Xodia.
- Xodia, Xodia, sorry.
- Obelisk.
- Obelisk is a different one.
Sorry, Xodia, yeah.
So it was the five pieces of Xodia, right?
- Well, you could, that
was like a starter deck
that you could buy, everyone had Xodia.
- Yeah.
- Right, but not everyone
had all the pieces, right?
Because the Xodia, cause you
usually in those starter packs,
you'd get one piece of Xodia.
- I remember in the UK,
I don't know why I just did remember this?
They literally sold a
deck that had all the five
Xodia that you could do
buy for like 20 bucks.
- Really?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Because for us, it was
like the old the booster pack
was like you'd maybe get
one piece of equipment.
- Yeah, there was booster pack,
there was like starter
packs, I had all of them.
- Yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, so we didn't have
that luxury in Australia,
so the only way someone could
physically get all pieces
of the Xodia, was to do a
bunch of hustling and trading
and get all the pieces and
so as like a 10-year-old,
I had like one Xodia
thing, but I was like,
I love this guy so much, I
wanna collect all of them.
All my friends have
all these other pieces,
but they're not gonna trade it to me
because they realize the value of Xodia
on this market right now.
So I did ask, went up to
my dad and I was like,
father you work for a
printing company, don't you?
You have a high quality
printers at your work.
Here's some P and Gs of Xodia.
(all laughing)
Could you print them out onto card paper
and give them to me?
- [Connor] Yeah, yeah.
- Any full-on like printed out
these like pirated fucking Xodia
and they were like shitty,
like 240P qualities of Xodia, right?
But as a 10-year-old, you don't
know the fucking difference.
- Oh shit, I just got mad flashbacks.
Holy fuck!
- So I would come to school
and I'd be like boys,
I have all my pieces of Xodia.
- On terrible, like printed ink stained.
- One of them is in like 1080 P
and the other is like three pixels.
(all laughing)
Kids are like, "Wow!"
It's like, I can trade them off
to you as well, if you want.
- Man, I remember that like,
I really, really wanted like,
I think there was like
element heroes or something
and there's like Yu-Gi-Oh
XD collection or something.
- [Joey] Right, right, right.
- And my friend had them all,
but I wish I looked a little closer
because he traded me them
and I was like I want them
pretty badly and then I
got them and I was like,
oh wait.
They're like the descriptions really weird
and it was all just like gibberish,
like fake Chinese sounding
stuff and then I realized,
when I looked a little
closer, it was like printed
all like fucked and I was
like, wait, I just got hustled.
Yeah, it was all fucking
and I was like, so sad.
I was like, where the
fuck did you get this.
- You literally got scammed
into a Chinese knockoff.
- But like you feel them, they look good.
It doesn't look bad.
Then when you look at
the quality a little more
and you're like, oh wait.
- Enhance.
- Yeah and then you see like the text
and you're like why is it weird
fucking like Chinese sounding ass thing.
- If you wanna see something
like anxiety-inducing right?
So I remember I talked
about rhystic studies before
about how he makes magic videos.
So in his Black Lotus videos,
so like black load is a thing,
like one of the rarest cards
or expensive magic.
Most expensive cards,
so he talks about how
you would like figure out
what a fake one is to a real one
and apparently one of the
ways they used to test this
is called the bend test
where you will take this card
and you will literally have to bend it.
Like, imagine this is the card,
so you literally have to bend it there
and if it's a real card,
it won't crease at all,
but seeing this like $2,000
card being bent like that,
no matter if it bends or not,
I get anxiety and I have
zero knowledge about magic
or any investment in magic at all.
- All I know is there's
a video where a guy
just casually talking
and he's opening packs
and then he opens it and
he gets a Black Lotus
and he starts.
(Connor screaming)
Like that, it's so funny.
He's like casually talking
and then just starts freaking out.
I gotta find the link to
that clip, it's so weird.
- [Narrator] And then the other on is boo!
Holy boosh!
(Narrator giggling)
That's a fucking Black Lotus.
Holy God.
- That's like the one
thing I've been enjoying
about like this resurgence of
like opening Pokemon cards.
It's just like people
just like casually talking
and then just pulling
something really and be like.
- People turn it into gambling.
That's flat return.
- Pretty much.
- Cause if you turn
anything into gambling,
it's 10 times more fun.
- Is this how people feel
when they watch us roll
for fucking "Gacha" you on this?
- Yeah, the exactly.
This is why I went on a rant.
- This is why "Gacha"
streamed for a long time.
Did so fucking well cause
people love it when.
Like that dude who fucking, that Japanese,
like streamer, who was,
what was he fucking doing?
He was doing Arknights rolling.
- There was a guy rolling in Arknights,
he was dressed up as a Yogi.
- [Garnt] Yeah, that's
right and he had life?
- [Connor] Yeah, every
time he did a "Gacha" poll,
like his life points would go
down and the Yogi was like.
And he was like screaming
- He did like a fool, voice acting.
- Yeah, he was voice
acting and then he was like
and when he pulled every
time he would make it sound
like he was like summoning.
- He would like draw.
- Yeah, he was like draw and then--
- That sounds amazing.
- It was fucking amazing.
- It fun really fucking good clip.
It's so funny.
Hopefully we can play
it for like one second.
It's really funny.
I'm like, God, that's way too much act.
- Yeah.
I can't be bothered to like come up
with like exciting things
like that for streams
which is why I'm always
impressed with like
how recently you've been doing.
- I mean, I feel like at that point
you have to treat streams
the ways the same way
you treat YouTube videos.
- Yeah, that's what I
kinda I do sometimes.
I mean, right now when
I'm just playing Apex
over and over again, I'd
already say it that way,
but like when I'm doing certain things,
I do think of it as like,
oh, just think of it as
if you're making a video.
- All right.
- Yeah.
- And then just talk to the audience
that happened to also be
watching you made this video.
That's the way I see it
and I think that when
you think of it like that
it's a lot easier to
actually make good content
live streaming,
but if you don't have
that frame of reference
of how does it feel to make a video?
Cause obviously we have like
five years of experience
of talking to the camera, making a video,
but if you'd never had any of those,
it's like, how do I explain
how you should behave?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Good content, but then again,
I think I've still like a
lot that I can improve on,
so I'm getting there.
- I mean, it's a different field,
but the way I see it is
that, I think either of us
can become successful streamers.
I just think I don't have
the energy to put into it
because I would have to use the energy
that I put into making YouTube videos
into making Twitch streams.
They come like whole and--
- I mean, there's, there's
so many YouTubers here
end up just stopping YouTube
and gotta be a Twitch streamer
or vice versa,
it's normally YouTube
has become too expensive.
- For me, the thing
that is just stopping me
from making that transition is the fact
that I wouldn't be able
to take a vacation.
- Yeah, that's like YouTube.
Before I moved to Japan,
people didn't know
that I didn't do any work for a month
cause I was busy doing stuff,
but I prepared enough videos in advance
like everything was
running perfectly smooth.
- [Joey] Right, right.
- But I was able to take a month off.
- [Joey] Exactly.
- Which is like, oh my God, that's nuts.
- You take a month off as a streamer,
like basically your fucked.
- People would know.
You just disappear off
the face of the earth.
- Yeah, pretty much.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, which is why, I don't know.
Right now it's just like a fun
little side hobby right now,
but I've noticed that
I tend to, I use still,
when I would do YouTube videos,
once I finished with the video,
I would think about, alright,
what's the next YouTube
video I'm gonna make?
And I would think about that all day.
What am I gonna make?
What am I gonna do?
Oh, I can make this, I can make that,
but like now I don't
really think that way.
I think like, I plan what
videos I'm going to do
and then I don't really think about them.
I just kind of, until the
day comes where I'm making it
I'm like, all right, trying
to make a YouTube video
which I feel is more
healthier in some ways,
but it feels weird.
It feels like I care less,
but I think it's a good thing.
I don't know.
- I've had to try and change my mentality
towards that as well,
where especially hanging out with you guys
and just all constantly
compared to you guys
feeling like I'm behind schedule
and that's because I'm very like,
my content is very like inspiration based.
I find it so hard to work on a video
if I don't feel like working on the video.
I can't just like force the video out,
so I have to basically try
and schedule enough ideas
ahead of videos I wanna work on
in order for me to be able
to meet that like schedule.
- See, I think inspiration
is a little bullshit.
I think, I think you can't
rely on inspiration at all.
- [Garnt] Right.
- I think if you did
what you did for the BBC.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- You don't have a choice
if inspiration or not.
- Yeah, I mean, it's a
different career path, right?
I mean, it's comparing like a
office job to a creative path.
- Yeah, but I think for any creative field
it's important to discipline yourself to--
- Well, yeah.
- It's something you have
to learn, but it's just--
- If I get inspiration,
it's fantastic, I love it,
but it's so fleeting and
motivation is so fleeting as well,
it's like, you just have to
discipline yourself to work.
- I'm kind of like halfway
in between I think.
Like, yeah, of course if I
have to, if time is crunching
and I have to record something
in order to make the deadline
then obviously, regardless
of if I'm feeling inspired
or not I'll have to do
it, but for the most part,
it's like, I wake up in
the morning and I think,
okay, do I have to record today?
Then okay, I'll record,
but if I don't have to
and I don't feel like it, I'm
not gonna fucking force myself
to do it.
- Yeah, I mean there's some
days where my mood is so bad
that I'm clear it's gonna
come off in the video,
so I just don't wanna do it,
but then it also in that time,
okay, if I was gonna make a video,
well, I can't do that today,
I'll do something else that's productive
that can force me to
keep on top of things.
I don't know.
- But like recently I feel like
I haven't really had that
choice because I think the past
like four videos I've recorded this week
have all been pre-scheduled
on like certain days
and certain times, right?
- Yeah, I mean that's what I try and do.
I try and leave a lot of
videos that are in the works,
a lot of videos that are ahead,
so there's always something I can work on.
I don't like to just
finish a video and be like,
I got nothing, what am I doing?
What's next?
Huh?
I think it's good to have
multiple things your working on.
- It's like, you have
to plan for the next one
as your making the previous one.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, which is also a thing
that's quite difficult for
the way I used to work.
Cause I used to like, I had
to do one thing at a time.
- Yeah, same, same.
- But now yeah, I've got--
- Now I'm juggling like
seven different videos.
- Yeah, something like
that, I've got quite a lot.
- For me, I'm either working on seven
or I have no idea what I'm working on.
No in-between and I need to change that,
but that's why I feel
like I find it so scary
if I was a Twitch streamer,
cause the Twitch streamer,
you have to start streaming
no matter what mood you're in
and I feel like that it's
so much harder to hide that
on a Twitch stream rather
than a YouTube channel,
where you can just--
- Yeah, because it's constantly on camera.
- Yeah.
- It's true.
I mean, I think the one
thing that's even worse
than starting the stream
when you're in a bad mood
is when your mood sours midstream.
- Oh, yeah.
- You totally shit God.
- I can call that.
- When you'll start, liken whole happy--
- You'll start in like an hour
and then maybe you'll get
like a text from someone
that's like telling you like bad news
or maybe someone will say something
that's like real fucking mood
or maybe something happened,
like the stream starts to go wrong.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like when stuff starts going wrong
whilst you're streaming, it is
so much more mentally taxing
than when if then starting
the stream in a bad mood
cause you're like, it can't get worse.
I'm already in a bad mood.
- It's like fucking up on stage
in front of an audience, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Versus just up in a recording booth.
- Right, right, yeah.
- It's big difference.
- Like some fucking clown.
This actually didn't bother me that much,
but this is like an example of something
that could happen, so like
whilst I was streaming one time
something happened on my discord server,
where one of the mods
made someone else a mod
who was pretending to be a mod.
So someone joined my
discord server saying, "Hi."
For some reason, I'm
not a moderate anymore
and they have the same profile picture
and the same name as a moderator
and someone else on my server thought,
"Oh yeah, that checks out.
"That makes total sense."
Gave the moderator and then
they just start injecting
a bunch of bots into my server
and started like spamming it,
so my discord server completely got raided
whilst I was streaming
and the whole purpose of
this person doing this
was to do it to people
who are streaming live,
so they could get a reaction.
So I'm there, it's happening
and all my chat is like,
"Connor, Connor, your
fucking discord's on fire"
and I'm like, oh, okay.
All right.
I mean, it'll get dealed with.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Who cares.
- Yeah, it's something
you can deal with later.
- Yeah, that's like that,
but it's frustrating
when everyone was like, "Bro,
bro, you need to look at this.
"Look at this thing."
I'm like, I don't really give a shit,
like I'll deal with it later.
- [Joey] Yeah, yeah.
- But I was good cause
that guy was going around
trying to film TikToK reactions
of streamers getting angry
and I was like glad I didn't
know that at the time,
but I was like, I'm glad
I didn't fucking react
cause I was like, oh, okay, cool.
- Sounds like an asshole,
dick thing to move.
- Yeah, don't do that.
- Who does this shit?
People want attention, right?
It is what it is, nothing new.
- Yeah, nothing new you in the world.
- You just gotta deal with people
who always look in to attack you.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I get that sometimes.
I get every now and then
these like obviously people
who are just coming into Twitch chat
just to fucking get a reaction out of you,
just spam bullshit and the
best thing I do that just works
is like, I respond to them,
but in the most dead pan
fucking voice ever where it's like--
- Your normal--
- Yeah, literally just my
normal like talking voice
as if I'm like responding
to chat and sure enough
they eventually just go away
because that's what they want in the end.
In the end they want you to
be like, how fucking dare you
say something like that.
You're such an asshole.
- I don't know, I already
worry too much about it.
I just stare at them,
do what they wanna do.
- Yeah, but like a lot of streamers
who are just starting off can't
really process that, right?
You're just buying into the bait.
- It's hard to wrap your head around
that people are just gonna
do mean things to you
and you don't know why.
- It's nothing personal.
- It's nothing personal,
people just do this.
- And it's sad that, that's
part of the job, right?
I could like, there's someone
out there who I have no idea
who they are, I have no
interaction with them ever,
I've never spoken to
them and for some reason
they just wanna see bad shit happen to me.
I'm like that's really
difficult to accept that,
that's a reality.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Cause it takes you a few years
I think to like actually accept that.
- Yeah.
- Right?
- [Joey] Absolutely.
- I don't know when I started
just kind of like getting
over it and just being like,
all right, you know what?
It's gonna happen.
I feel like it was like
two, three years ago,
I was just like--
- Probably when it happened enough times
and you just kind of get used
to it and it's sad enough--
- Yeah, you can't do anything about it.
You just gotta not let it ruin your day.
- You think about a logically, right?
Your being like, well
I've never interacted
with this person, I don't know
what this person looks like
or what they're like as a person.
They don't know what
they look like, right?
I've never interacted with them.
So they're obviously
not saying all this shit
out of any logical basis.
- Yeah.
- So why would I take any logical basis
out of what they're saying?
- No, it's true, it's true.
I guess it was always to
be sad as long as I'm like,
man if they actually just spoke to me,
I'm sure they'd pretty
see that I'm a nice guy
and they wouldn't wanna do this.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah, that's the thing.
- Speaking of assholes online.
I wanna quick rant.
- Okay, go for it.
- Because I know we've talked
about "Attack On Titan," like plenty.
- All right, all right, here we go.
- Great start.
- Is it the weekly
"Attack On Titan".
- The weekly "Attack
On Titan" rant segment.
I'm getting so fucking tired of spoilers.
It's gotten to the point now
where my enjoyment of this
is getting fucking ruined
because of spoilers online.
Like logging on to Twitter now,
especially on a Monday, right?
It's like I'm trying not to be spoiled
on the "Attack On Titan."
It's like trying to go to
like a crowded hospital
without a face mask and
expecting not to get Covid.
That's like it's, I've been spoiled now
on so many plot points
of "Attack On Titan"
that I feel like as someone
who likes to binge shows
and as someone who doesn't wanna,
I don't wanna keep up with
it like weekly, right?
But I feel like I'm being held at gunpoint
just to keep up with this weekly.
- Yeah, I feel you on that.
- You should go through the Wiki
and get every character name
and you should mute them on Twitter.
- That's what I've done.
I've done that and yet still
I would be on a run for it.
- It sips through the cracks.
- There's no way to stop the cracks
and what I don't understand
is why is it that
when we talk about spoiler culture,
why is it that with a show
like "Attack On Titan"
it's fine to talk about
it as soon as it airs?
- It's because everyone, all
the "Attack On Titan" fans
expect that everyone is watching it
as the episode comes out.
- Because we have something
like the "Avengers."
- So wait, so wait, you think
it's not okay to talk about it
after it airs?
- I mean, I think there
should be a buffer period.
Like we have this for the "Avengers."
Why can we not have this
for "Attack On Titan"
or any other TV show?
- What's your buffer period?
I don't remember.
- Yeah, I mean, there was a
massive fucking buffer period
where like the directors
and everyone was just like,
"Please do not talk about
the "Avengers End Game"
"for like a good two, three weeks."
And there is just no buffer
period for like TV shows
and like, we're living in an
age where it's like on demand.
So it's not even the same as it was before
where things are airing on TV
and people are watching at the same time.
Everyone's watching at different times.
It's literally an on demand service.
This episode is sponsored by BookWalker.
Gentlemen, have you ever
heard of BookWalker before?
- No, explain it to me.
- It is an official ebook
store and app for digital manga
and light novels.
- Wow.
- This is Maylene's collection right here.
You've well, my God you've
normally did this out.
That is not.
Actually "Attack On Titan"
front row, yeah Maylene.
- So this is the list
Maylene list I've ever seen.
- Okay Maylene.
- Sorry, go back to it.
- Yeah, okay.
Why don't you get the app
on your Android iOS device.
You can view your purchases
and read them offline
if you download them.
- And the best of all you
can customize the bookshelf
like Maylene has.
She just put the "Trash Taste" logo on it
like the true fan she is.
- Most importantly, they
are simultaneously releasing
the "Attack On Titan" manga.
- Is that a good manga?
I've never heard it.
- Guys, guys, stop talking.
There's only two chapters left,
so if you don't wanna get spoiled,
read it right now on global.bookwalker.jp
- The second to last
chapter was just released
three days ago.
- What?
- So check it out right now.
- I'm going there right now.
- Link's in the description.
- Sorry guys.
I'm going right now.
- "Attack On Titan" is a good manga.
- I just came back to confirm
I'm reading the new chapter,
it is amazing, it's amazing gone.
It's not good, it's amazing.
- Okay.
- Go and read it on
global.bookwalk.jp right now.
(Joey laughing)
Back to the episode.
I really like the community
aspect of when an episode airs,
everyone talks about
it, I kind of like that
- No, but there're ways to talk about it
in ways that are not
spoiling and there're places
there're like open forums
that you have to physically go
and look up, right?
- When I talk about the show on Twitter,
I try not to mention spoilers.
- Yeah, I know.
- Yeah.
- Every tweet you've tweeted
about "Attack On Titan"
it's fine because you're not spoiling it,
but you still leave open
for discussion, right?
- But there're some--
- I mean, I still mute it right away.
- There're some fucking kids
who just do not understand that
and they're just like,
"Yeah, of course everyone is watching it."
- (indistinct) 4K picture,
I can't believe this character died.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It is like, oh my God.
- It is like there's
like some motherfuckers
who will literally like put a full spoiler
and then like put a spoiler warning
five minutes after they just
spoiled with the fucking thing
they talked about man.
Right now, social media is
like setting a minefield.
- I've understood the
whole like spoiler warning
at the beginning of a tweet.
It was like, how about
you just don't tweet it
- Actually it's I honestly not gonna lie,
it saved me a few times.
- [Garnt] Really?
- Cause I'll read the
top of it about a show
and I'll see a picture
and I'll quickly scroll
cause I'm like, all right, sick.
That's for the warning actually saved me.
- All right, to me, it's
just the most pointless
fucking warning.
- It's better than nothing, right?
- No, I would rather just you
not spoiling it to be honest.
- But I understand, right?
Cause "Attack On Titan,"
I wish I could tweet about
like the details of the show
a little bit more, but I know that
because I've like quite a large following
that I'm gonna have
spoil it up for someone,
so I don't wanna do that.
- Right, right.
- Yeah.
- Like I literally like every time I--
- But I do think that if you
go on Twitter on a Monday
in Japan and you haven't
watched the newest episode,
honestly, that's kind of on you.
- Well, thanks for the
victim blame right there.
- So if you guys don't
know "Attack On Titan" airs
I think in the evening in
America, but it airs like 5:00 a.m
on a Monday for us.
So first thing I do every
Monday when I wake up
is I watch the episode,
I don't open Twitter,
I don't do any cause I'm not being funny.
I know the internet,
they're gonna spoil it.
There's nothing you
can say here or ever do
that will stop them from doing that,
so why not just watch it?
- I feel though that this
"Attack On Titan" incident
is like almost unprecedented.
Like I don't think
there's ever been an anime
that has been where the
amount of spoilers on Twitter
has been this prelevant.
- There's been none and I remember
because "Attack On Titan"
season three, part two,
I thought, I got spoiled on
some like minor things, but--
- Is it that bad?
I don't see that many spoilers online.
- I see so many.
- I see it on Twitter trending page.
- Yeah!
- Oh!
- Like that's how you
know it's getting bad.
When literally when you go to
Twitter trending some weeks
and I've seen it some weeks,
it's it shows you the tagline
or the hashtag or
whatever word is trending
and then underneath gives the
spoiler and I'm like what?
- Okay, that is a little scammy.
Okay, I can understand.
- That's never happened
to any anime series.
- That has never happened.
Like recently I got, or like I knew like,
it's the equivalent of being like,
yo, something's gonna
happen with this character.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Nine times out of 10,
it's probably a death.
It's probably gonna be about death
and the problem is that "Attack On Titans"
is one of the easiest like
shows to spoil out there
cause it only takes like
one sentence or one word.
- I'm pretty sure I've
seen pictures of stuff,
of like where the current manga is at
and that like I'm sure that I
have seen very glimpse vicks
and when I see it and I
recognize a character,
I'm like, I skip, but I've seen it
and I don't know what it is, so I'm like,
well, if they have no
context this picture,
I don't know what's going
on, I'm not gonna be spoiled
until the moment I see that frame.
- Okay, I actually disagree about that.
- Yeah, I disagree too.
- I mean, it's still like
spoils your experience a bit
cause there's been like for example,
there's been so many, like,
let's say anime or manga
or where you see like a meme panel, right?
And this meme gets passed
around and you don't know
the context it, but then you finally read
or watch whatever shows
everyone's memed about
and then it could be like this read,
some of the most serious
moments in like media
has been like, just ruined for me
because I've seen the meme of
it and so the moment happens
and it takes you out and be like,
oh, that was, that was
the moment they got memed.
Like, right now I'm reading "Tokyo Ghoul"
because I wanna see if the "Tokyo Ghoul"
manga readers are right?
And I know when that fucking
Carnegie final comes up,
I'm gonna laugh.
Like, I don't know what
the context of it is.
- Isn't that fun though?
That's fun?
- No, it is not fun.
- That's fun, that's fun, I had fun.
- Biggest to me, like I've
had this happen where I--
- I'm not saying that
it's okay to post pictures
from the manga, I don't think anyone
should be fucking posting
pictures in the manga.
- No, no, but what I'm saying--
- People are still posting
pictures from the anime,
fresh after the anime just airs.
- What I'm saying though is
that people should just avoid
posting it entirely
because even if, right?
You like read the spoiler
warning and you see the picture
for like a fraction of a second, right?
Like, wait, just like no,
I'm not gonna watch it.
Somewhere in the back of your head,
that image is subconsciously planted.
- No, no, no, it is, right?
- Yeah.
- But here's what I've realized, right?
When you see an image of a show, right?
That you're really into and
it's like it could be ages away,
you're making your own theory in your head
of why that image is happening.
- All right.
- Yeah.
- If you've seen it, right?
- And so most of the time
you're gonna be wrong, right?
It's not gonna be accurate.
So are you technically spoiled?
Because you've sort of seen something
that's given you a vague
idea of what you think
could be happening, but
you could be totally wrong.
Are you spoiled that?
- I honestly want to come into a show
with as least
a zero expectations as I can.
- Me too, me too.
But what I'm saying is that
like, if seeing one frame
of a panel of a manga and anime,
obviously if it's literally a
character dead on the floor,
yeah, okay, that's very obvious.
- Yeah, that's being
heavily posted around,
- Yeah, yeah, but if there's
a shot of something happening
that I can't quite make out, I
don't look at it long enough.
I just have some kind of vague feeling
in the back of my head.
I don't really think that's a spoiler
- Because something
like that happened when
I decided to finally watch "Demon Slayer."
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And like the first
example we ever had at that
was when episode 19 was
trending on Twitter, right?
And everyone was posting
pictures and gifts of that scene.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And of course, because I knew immediately
on the trending page, it says
"Demons Slayer" episode 19
and at that point I hadn't
started here, right?
And I'm like, wow,
eventually I wanna get to it.
So obviously I'm not gonna look at it.
I'm gonna try and avoid all pictures,
but obviously when you're on Twitter
or your on the internet,
you're gonna see like fraction of a frame
or a fraction of an image, right?
And not gonna lie, when
I finally caught up
to "Demon Slayer" and I got
to that scene in episode 19,
I was like, this is impressive,
but I feel I would have
been even more impressed
if I had no idea that this was coming up,
like everybody else, if
I'd not experienced it.
- Does it take away?
- A little bit.
- It does take away.
- To be honest.
I feel like it does absolutely take away.
- I can understand that, but I don't know.
- I was like this is epic,
but this could have been
fucking mind blowing
like it was for everybody else.
- Yeah.
Cause I mean, like I said,
we we've thought about spoiler culture
when something as big as the "Avengers"
was aired in cinemas.
- Well, like "Game of Thrones."
- Hope to put that, but you can argue
that when it is such a big moment
in any media that obviously
it deserves to be talked
about the moment it happens
that you're like, oh my God
please tell me someone
else has watched this,
this is insane.
- I feel like it hasn't caught
up with the culture right now
because I could understand
that for example,
when things were airing on
TV, you had one run of it
and people would go
around the water cooler
and discuss what just happens,
but now, we're in a time
when it's on demand.
People watch things when they want to
and yet we still have the same like idea
around spoiling things as if
people were watching things
on TV because I don't wanna watch things
as soon as they are.
I like binging it, hat's
just how I enjoy it.
- You should adapt to the way
that you can't on Twitter.
- This is why I missed
like dedicated forums
because with a dedicated
forum on a show, right?
You won't know anything
about the spoils of the show
unless you decide to click on the forum.
- No, cause the way to
adapt is just like I said--
- How do you solve this
problem on Twitter?
- There is no.
- This is never gonna go away,
so why not just adapt to what's happening
cause you can't change it all the time,
change with the time bro.
- Because I don't wanna
fucking wait an entire week
for the next episode, I wanna binge it.
- Yeah, cause like--
- I hate watching shit weekly.
- The reason I said it was
because when this idea came up
for the "Avengers," everyone
was like, yes, good, finally,
someone said it.
- That is bullshit.
I saw people swirling it on Twitter.
- Yeah, but probably not
nearly as much as without them.
- But the thing is--
- I don't think it mattered.
- And like everyone got
shamed for doing it.
Everyone was just like,
"Yo, you did a bad thing.
"Don't fucking do this."
Yeah, when we talk about TV shows
and especially now with
the "Attack On Titan"
it's just everyone's
just doing it willy nilly
and the mentality is,
well, everyone's doing it.
So I guess that's okay and
that's just acceptable.
- This is such a hard topic to discuss.
I wish I had like more time to prepare
like an actual rebuttal,
but I mean, I understand
where you're coming from.
I just think that in
the age that we live in
now, it's always gonna be like that,
so why not just adapt to what's happening.
- Yeah, I mean, I like for
me, I grew up watching anime
and manga, I mean, I've gotten
used to just watching it
in a bubble, I like enjoying
like my entertainment
in a bubble and it's only recently
that I've gotten a different
kind of enjoyment to see,
like to discussing it with
friends and everything like that,
but when it's something that's, I mean--
- In a perfect world, right?
You'd go in a coma and you would wake up
and the doctor's like,
"Bro, here's your crunchy roll account.
"Here's "Attack On Titan."
"Don't get up yet, just
pretend you're still asleep.
"Watch the rest of the
episodes and then leave
"and then go on Twitter."
That's the perfect world, right?
Where you can experience it,
full run, no breaks, no weeks,
no bullshit on Twitter, but
that's just not how it works.
- Yeah, I know it's not how it works.
All I'm trying to argue
is that, why is it this?
Why is it like, why do people
not have a problem with this?
- I think people do
have a problem with it.
They're just kind of like--
- I think especially in time like--
- Can't do anything about it.
- In times like now, right?
Where everyone's also
at home all the time,
who you're gonna talk to?
Your mom about "Attack On Titan?"
No, you're gonna go on Twitter
and talk about with your friends
cause everyone's at home.
- But there's other venues to do that in.
Like isn't that the whole reason
why fucking discord was invented?
Just so you can create a private room
where you know the people
you're discussing it with.
- There are some people who,
not me personally.
- Yeah.
- They don't really talk about
stuff with their friends,
they just like to throw it
into a void, which is okay.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- But people like that need to understand
that no one gives a
shit about what you say.
- Like what I'm trying to say
is if you want to discuss it,
why not discuss it on like
the relevant subs vitus
and stuff like that.
- Probably where it belongs.
- Yeah, I mean, there's
a difference between
discussing spoilers in a
dedicated here are the episode,
here's the episode, let's
just go on a thread versus
let's just post screenshots
and stuff publicly on Twitter
that anyone can see.
- It's the whole assumption that, yes,
everybody who was a fan
of "Attack On Titan"
and anyone who had ever
search the "Attack On Titan"
is searching it because
they're watching it weekly
and it's that whole missed
assumption where it's like
and that's why, again,
like if you wanna discuss
the fucking episode that just happened,
do it on a private discord server,
do it on a fucking subreddit
do it on a fucking closed forum.
- What we need is spoiler etiquette.
We need a system in place
where everyone just agrees,
"Hey, this is how you're gonna spoil it."
- Yeah, I mean, that's
all I was talking about.
I was talking about--
- That's never gonna happen.
- Yeah, it's never gonna happen.
- What I was trying to say is,
it's never gonna get to
a point where everyone
follows this etiquette and everyone like,
this is like a hard and fast
rule that everyone will follow.
No, all I'm saying is like,
why is there no ethicacy
around this where people were just like,
"Yeah, that would be--"
- There should be common sense.
- There's all also you gotta
think to the fact that okay,
90% of people who were posting stuff,
aren't intending it so they ruin your day,
but there's 10% of people who are hoping
that they get people who they spoil.
They get enjoyment
knowing ruin someone's--
- What I'm saying is like,
what it seemed around the "Avengers"
is that it was that 10% of people
that the only spoilers you got
were people who are really looking to ruin
other people's day, right?
But at least we can all
point to them and say,
yeah, they were an asshole.
- Yeah.
So you wanted us to become
more of a normalized
asshole thing to put any--
- Yeah.
- The fact that 90% of people
who were posting spoilers
on Twitter about a "Tap On Time"
aren't being called out for
it, I think it's the problem.
- Do you think it's,
I mean cause the anime
is arguably more popular than the manga.
- Yeah.
- Right?
I think it's a little
dickish people to post panels
from the manga when you
can just talk about them,
not post them to Twitter when,
you know that the majority
of the people are anime only.
- Right.
- Right?
That kind of annoys me cause
that makes sense to me.
- But even still just,
just keep it privately bro.
- I get it posting the
anime cause I'm like,
all right, everyone's watching the anime--
- I found it a real problem
where the last time I stream,
literally the first
thing I had to say was,
don't ask me questions
about that "Tap One Time"
because of the fact that
people will like type to me
in the chat immediately, like five minutes
into me streaming binge,
"Hey Joey, what are your
thoughts on the "Tap One Time?"
I'm like, I'm not gonna
fucking talk about it
cause why would you assume
that I've caught up to it?
Why would you assume everyone in this chat
has caught up to it?
I'm not gonna do that.
So to avoid spoilers,
let's just not fucking
talk about it at all.
That's the best way to do it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You wanna talk about
it, do it in your own
fucking DMs.
- I mean like it's a
different conversation to say,
how much spoilers do ruin
a show or ruin something?
I mean, that's a different conversation.
- That's a good conversation going.
- I just wish there was
some basic etiquette.
- You know what I mentioned
earlier about the picture,
that when you see a picture
or a frame or an image
from an anime, you're like, oh man,
I wonder what that's all about.
Why has Conoci thrown his head back?
Why he been doing that?
I kind of think it's pretty
cool when you have an idea
of why this is happening
and that it's totally wrong.
You're like, oh, that's how it happened.
I thought this was gonna happen.
I kind of liked that.
That's kind of cool.
Not that I want, please don't do this,
but sometimes when it happens,
you don't feel too spoiled
and you're like--
- Yeah, but I feel it's a
bit of a different story
with the Conoci thing, right?
Because it's like in the manga
that's a really serious scene
and all I can imagine is (indistinct).
That's all that is playing in
the back of my head, right?
But like in the funny way, right?
So it really does kind of like,
it's not so much a spoiler,
it's just kind of like the
gap between what you expected
and what actually happened is
like a disappointment, right?
- Cause I feel like it really
much depends on the show.
Cause like, for example,
I don't think it's physically
possible to spoil with Jojo.
- It's not, you can post a panel,
you can fully explain what's
happening in the scene
and it won't prepare you for it.
- Yeah, yeah yeah, exactly.
- Exactly.
- I remember that time that
limp dick fought biscuit soup
and they kissed each other
to death and you're like,
oh, is that spoiler?
Yeah, I mean, yeah (indistinct)
- Yeah, to her I know.
That is how the fight ends.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, but like something like Jojo,
it doesn't hurt your
enjoyment of the series.
Part of that is the
- Honestly, it pretty makes it better
if someone explains
what's happening to you--
- You totally understand it, right?
- I mean, you're like, oh.
- But a character dying
in "Attack On Titan,"
anyone can understand
that and it ruins it.
- Yeah, it's a minefield right now.
I just wanted to go on a quick
first world problem rant.
This isn't actually an important problem.
I just wanted to go in an off Titan rant.
- Yeah and the spoiler culture
is pretty fun to talk about.
Just discuss it, what's
going on with that.
- Yeah, because like,
have you ever been spoiled
in like any big plot points
that has kind of ruined
your enjoyment of every, any show
or you think you would like--
- I'm amazed at some shows
that I didn't get spoiled,
like with certain plot
points in "Attack On Titan,"
I am like, how the fuck did
I not get spoiled on this?
This shit was so goddamn obvious
that everyone was pretty talking about it
and I'm the only idiot that didn't know.
I mean, obviously I won't say it.
- [Garnt] Right.
- But there're moments.
In recent memory, I can't
remember last time I got spoiled.
- I got spoiled on the
"Code Geass" ending.
- Oh!
- Oh no!
- Which is why I'm so fucking
passionate about this,
- My condolences man.
- Which is why I'm so
fucking passionate about it
cause I didn't even finish season one
when I got spoiled on that shit.
- How did you get spoiled?
What happened?
- Because I was on some
forum where they were talking
about "Code Geass"
and I didn't realize that,
oh there's a second season
of "Code Geass" and
people were talking about,
"Yeah, so the last three
episodes of season two
"was like, that was a crazy ending."
Was it?
I was like,
Is there's two seasons.
- You can talk about the "Code
Geass" ending now, right?
It's like Bruce Willis at the
end of, everyone knows it.
- I think my buffer is like 10 years.
- I guess.
- I feel like everyone has seen it, right?
You can spoil it, it's
common knowledge, right?
- Maybe we shouldn't be
cause otherwise it will sound
really fucking hypocritical.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Once enough time has passed
and a show is iconic enough,
I think it is totally
fair game to talk about
cause it's part of pop
culture at that point,
but the cookie you're
sending is universally loved
and often cited as one of
the best endings in anime.
You should know how it ends.
- To me though, like that buffer
is still too small, right?
Like I can go ahead
and spoil like something
like, "Soylent Green"
cause that's like a
60-year-old movie, right?
But like, I feel "Code Geass"
is like they're still
kids today coming in,
probably having no idea what
the show is about, right?
- Yeah.
- So I don't want, look,
I've been through the pain,
especially with "Code Geass,"
so I'm not gonna say shit.
- Yeah, I mean, like I
got spoiled on something
of a similar capacity I'd say.
I got spoiled on like the
halfway point of "Death Note"
where saw something big happens.
Yeah, I was a manga spoiler as well.
- That's the worst.
That's the worst.
I feel that's worse than
getting spoiled on the ending
of "Death Note."
- That is worse than getting spoiled
on the ending of "Death Note."
- I think it's worse than
getting spoiled for in the end.
- Cause that was the ending
of "Death Note" for me.
- So that's, you talk about that, right?
(all laughing)
That's so iconic, you know what I mean?
Like there's some things in anime like--
- I feel like I need to
like make a survey of this
and like, depending on the survey results
is whether I can spoil it or not, right?
It's like dude 90% of
people who know me know
the halfway point of "Death Note?"
- It's like saying like fucking
Walter White makes meth.
Like yeah, that's universally no.
- No, it's not.
- Come on.
- It's not even close.
- I mean, I just think
that after a certain point
where something is so well
loved and so well-known
and so universally like
watched by everyone
instead of community,
that it is fair to just openly discuss it.
- Yeah.
- By the way, please
don't spoil "Code Geass"
and "Death Note" in the
comments of this episode
- It's been how many
years since "Death Note,"
is like what?
13?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, played early 2000s, right?
- 2006.
- Right?
- "Code Geass" was 2007, I think.
- Yeah.
So it's been a lot of time.
- I'm not gonna do it just in case,
but I think that it should be.
- What's your buffer?
What's your buffer?
- If I'm an anime fan, I would be like,
the first thing I'd be like,
what do you think of that?
Think of that?
(all laughing)
- Wow, you really just said that.
- There're some things, if
you say you are like a fan
of egg genre that you should know.
Like if you're like, I
love Bruce Willis movies
you should know that he's dead
in "The Sixth Sense," right?
Everyone knows, that's
like the meme spoiler.
- Let's just spoil all
the B plot twist of like,
but no, no, I get it, I get it.
That's that's like--
- Making me out to be the fucking bad guy.
- No, no, no, I mean, I get it
cause that's become
like part of pop culture
now I would say.
- Yeah, exactly, it's
not the show anymore.
The twist is so iconic that the twist--
- Has become part of pop culture itself
rather than watching the shows.
- I've never seen "The Sixth
Sense," but I know the twist
because everyone's like,
cause it's always used
as like anecdotally like,
oh it's like the ending.
Fuck, I haven't watched it.
I'm not gonna watch it now.
- Are you really not gonna watch it?
It's still a really good movie.
- I'm pretty gonna watch it at some point.
- Yeah, yeah, it's a little good movie.
- Yeah, because like,
I feel like right now,
how would you feel
if someone's spoiled
"Attack On Titan" for you?
- I think I'd be crushed
and I'd get over it.
You know what I mean?
- Would you get over it?
Cause I was not over when I
got spoiled for "Code Geass."
- It depends, what, how bad of a spoiler
we're talking, right?
- I'm talking like ending of "Code Geass"
levels of spoilers.
- And the ending of "Attack On Titan."
Someone spoiled the ending
of "Attack On Titan" for you.
- It depends what it was, right.
Cause if I already feel like
it's going in a certain
direction right now
and if the film was like
confirmed that it was going there,
I'd be like, kind of sucks that
you confirmed my suspicion,
but I'll get over it.
You know what I mean?
- Would you though?
- Yeah, I mean, cause I've
been spoiled on stuff before
and I've been like, you know what?
At the end of the day, the
experience is still a banger
and this ain't gonna ruin it.
- Right, right.
I mean, look, yeah, like granted,
like I finished "Code Geaas"
and even after knowing that spoiler.
- It doesn't spoil it, it
doesn't ruin it, right?
The scene's so goddamn good.
- It didn't ruin it,
but I'm thinking of like
the what if scenario
of if I wasn't spoiled, like
how much of a mind factor--
- If the scene is so
reliant on the fact that you
like don't need to know this plot point
that like the emotions,
the voice act in the music, the animation,
but all of that can't bring
in like an emotional reaction
out of you, then I don't think it deserves
to be like guarded in the first place.
- But at the same time,
I feel like it took
something away from you.
It took that fresh experience from you
because they're like, there are shows
like I've re-watched "Code Geass," right?
Fucking the ending is excellent
every time out of none,
but the like by far, the
most unique experience I had
was that first time that holy shit moment
where I experienced it for the first time.
- Absolutely.
- And you can only get that once.
- Yeah, I'm just trying
to be positive here.
Should I say if it gets spoiled man,
don't watch at the end of
the world, you gonna be okay.
The scene's still good,
it holds up, don't worry.
- I mean, there are even
shows where you enjoy more
the second time you watch it,
but I still value having
that first fresh experience
when I don't know what's gonna happen.
- Yeah, it's that first
moment that's so strong
that you look back on it years later
and be like it's that obligatory like,
I wish I could erase my mind about X show,
so I could experience it all over again.
Like that, to me, that was "Code Geass."
- Yeah.
- Because I was like--
- Probably because you
don't re-watch shows
which is why you don't care.
Your taking one, you've
put in a zip folder
and you file it away.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- Compress that shit.
- You compress that shit and
then you throw it in the trash.
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
- I'm not really (indistinct)
and I think that I'm in like
the middle of like, I care,
but I don't really care.
Like it's not gonna take
away my, if the show's good,
I'm still gonna enjoy it,
but I definitely feel that
most people are on the end of
I don't want anything spoiled for me,
don't tell me anything.
- Yeah.
I want like the full on experience.
I don't want someone.
Yeah, I'd rather fall on the experience
than someone just paraphrasing
it to me in a shit way.
- Yeah, yeah, exactly.
- I'm tired as fuck,
so we're gonna end this episode right now.
- You know who's not tired as fuck though?
Our patreons
- They're not tired of supporting us yet.
Look at these great people.
- They're hustling and bustling.
They are on that grind.
- Look at these great people.
- I better fair traded
my Pokemon cards to me.
They wouldn't be a little bitch about it
and asking for that.
- I bet they don't post "Attack On Titan"
spoilers on Twitter publicly.
- Yeah, don't do that please.
But hey, if you wanna support us
then make sure to go to
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also follow us on Twitter, the subreddit
and if you wanna listen
to our audio stuff,
go over to Spotify.
- [Garnt] Yeah and I think
that's basically everything, right?
- I think that's it.
- Who wants to do the outro today?
- The host?
- Didn't we didn't we just do the outro.
Is that not the outro.
- No.
- That was an outro, was it not?
- No, the final say.
- Yeah, the final say.
- Okay, bye.
- Okay.
- What you mean we did an outro?
- That was the most flacid
outro I ever heard in my life.
- [Connor] I am flacid gone.
(upbeat music)